This is Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. Growing up, I attended a Jesuit high school. I noticed that every weekend, my Catholic classmates and their families would line up and confess their sins to a priest. Some of those priests were also our teachers. They taught us history and geography and economics. I found myself wondering why in the world my classmates would fess up about the bad things they had done to the very teachers who held us to such strict account in the world. classroom. Nearly every religious and spiritual tradition has some version of the Catholic confessional. Everyone keeps secrets, but nearly everyone wants to share their secrets too.
这里是《隐藏的大脑》。我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。在成长过程中，我曾就读于一所耶稣会高中。我注意到，每到周末，我的天主教同学和他们的家人都会排队向神父告解自己的罪过。其中一些神父同时也是我们的老师。他们教我们历史、地理和经济学。我不禁纳闷，为什么我的同学会把他们做过的坏事，向那些在课堂上对我们要求如此严格的老师全盘托出呢？几乎每个宗教和精神传统都有天主教告解室的某种版本。每个人都有秘密，但几乎每个人也都想分享自己的秘密。
Turns out, we don't just want to be admired and loved. We also want to be seen. In our episode last week, we explored the costs of self-concealment. People who keep secrets have poorer physical and mental health. They are less likely to elicit help from others. If you miss that episode, you can find it in this podcast feed. It's titled Keeping Secrets. Today, we look at the psychological power of self-disclosure. Sharing more about what is happening in our lives with others turns out to be one of the best ways of winning friends and influencing people. Coming clean this week on Hidden Brain. We all keep secrets, and most of us know what it feels like to share a secret. It feels scary. It feels risky. It can also feel liberating, honest, courageous.
事实证明，我们不仅希望被崇拜和被爱，我们还希望被看见。在上周的节目中，我们探讨了自我隐瞒的代价。保守秘密的人身心健康状况较差。他们更不容易从他人那里获得帮助。如果你错过了那一期节目，你可以在这个播客动态中找到它。它的标题是《保守秘密》。今天，我们将探讨自我披露的心理力量。事实证明，与他人分享更多我们生活中的发生的事情，是赢得朋友和影响他人最好的方法之一。本周《隐藏的大脑》将为你揭露真相。我们每个人都保守着秘密，我们大多数人都知道分享秘密是什么感觉。这感觉很可怕。这感觉很冒险。这也可能让人感到解放、诚实和勇敢。
At Harvard University, psychologist Leslie John studies the psychology of secret keeping and the consequences of self-disclosure. Leslie, John, welcome to Hidden Brain. Thanks so much for having me. Leslie, when you were a doctoral student, you once found yourself at an academic conference party that went late into the night. Now psychologists and behavioral economists are like everyone else, So at one point in the evening, the topic of the conversation turned to embarrassments that people had experienced themselves. What kind of stories did people share? Yes. So we were at this conference, nerd jamboree, and we're sitting in a circle.
在哈佛大学，心理学家莱斯利·约翰研究保守秘密的心理学以及自我披露的后果。莱斯利·约翰，欢迎来到《隐藏的大脑》。非常感谢邀请我来。莱斯利，当你还是个博士生的时候，你曾参加过一个持续到深夜的学术会议派对。现在，心理学家和行为经济学家和其他人一样，所以在晚会上的某个时刻，谈话的主题转向了人们自己经历过的尴尬事情。大家都分享了什么样的故事？是的。所以我们当时在这个会议上，可以说是书呆子嘉年华，我们坐成一个圈。
It's late at night. And someone has the great idea to do, hey, let's play a game. Let's all go around the circle and share our most embarrassing story. And so, yeah, it was a mix of doctoral students like me, lowly doctoral students, and super fancy, a couple of very fancy professors. And so, of course, I wanted them to know of my existence and have a positive view of me. And so we start going around the circle and my fellow doctoral students there playing it safe, which is very smart in some sense,
那是深夜。然后有人出了个好主意，说：“嘿，我们玩个游戏吧。大家围成一圈，分享一下自己最尴尬的故事。”所以，是的，那是一群像我一样的博士生，卑微的博士生，还有超级大牛，几位非常厉害的教授。所以，当然，我希望他们知道我的存在，并对我有积极的看法。于是我们开始围着圈说，我的博士生同伴们都在求稳，从某种意义上说这非常明智，
and they're giving kind of humble, braggy answers. So, like, oh, the most embarrassing moment was when I discovered there was a typo in my abstract of my fancy journal article. Oh, no, the horror. So, yeah, kind of eye-rolly. I mean, I was, like, rolling my eyes on the inside. And then my turn came.
他们给出的回答有点像是在低调地炫耀。比如，哦，最尴尬的时刻是，我发现我那篇高大上的期刊文章的摘要里有一个拼写错误。哦，不，太可怕了。所以，是的，有点让人翻白眼。我的意思是，我当时在心里直翻白眼。然后轮到我了。
And, And kind of impulsively I decided in the moment to share my actually most embarrassing story ever, which entailed in college I was in a play. And there was this one scene that was just me and it was a really funny scene. And the audience was howling with laughter, which then made me howl with laughter, which I was laughing so hard that I peed myself and making matters worse. I was wearing pantyhose, not pants, dress and pantyhose. So it was like, I mean, I don't know. I've never seen a film of it. But in my mind, it's like a waterfall between my legs is what I envision the scene to me.
然后我有点冲动地决定在那个时刻分享我实际上有生以来最尴尬的故事，那就是我在上大学时参演了一部戏剧。其中有一场戏只有我一个人，那是一场非常有趣的戏。观众们笑得前仰后合，这让我也不禁笑得前仰后合，我笑得太厉害了，以至于尿裤子了，更糟糕的是。我穿的是连裤袜，而不是裤子，穿着连衣裙和连裤袜。所以就好像，我不知道。我从来没有看过它的录像。但在我的脑海里，我设想那场戏就像我腿之间挂着一道瀑布。
Oh, my gosh. My family was there too, and we've actually never spoken of it. So I just have blocked it from. But what I did in that moment, for some strange reason, I decided, let me share this actually embarrassing story. So I was the showstopper. What was the reaction in the group when you shared the story that evening? Laughter.
哦，天哪。我的家人当时也在场，而且我们其实从来没有谈起过这件事。所以我只是把它从记忆中屏蔽了。但我在那个时刻，出于某种奇怪的原因，我决定，让我分享这个其实很尴尬的故事吧。所以我成了全场最抢眼的人。那天晚上当你分享这个故事时，大家的反应是什么？笑声。
Laughter. Everybody was like, this is amazing. This is hilarious. I was in the moment I was also because everybody was enjoying it. We were having fun. But then the next morning when I woke up, I thought, oh God, what have I done? These like people who I want them to think I'm competent, I felt that pang of a disclosure hangover.
笑声。每个人都觉得，这太棒了。这太搞笑鸟。我当时也因为每个人都很享受而感到高兴。我们玩得很开心。但第二天早上醒来时，我想，天哪，我都做了些什么？这些人，我希望他们认为我很能干，我感到了那种披露后的宿醉感。
Like I just felt, oh, why did I do this? I just told them this story that's very undermining. So I thought I had like ruined my shots of ever getting a great job or being in high esteem from them, by them. I'm wondering whether your decision to tell that story, how has it aged over time? Is there still a choice that you regret? Not at all.
就像我只是觉得，我为什么要这么做？我刚刚把这个非常具有消极影响的故事告诉了他们。所以我以为我已经毁了我获得好工作或者赢得他们高度评价的所有机会。我想知道你当时决定讲那个故事的决定，随着时间的推移，它是如何发酵的？这仍然是一个你后悔的选择吗？一点也不。
not at all. In fact, now I view it as like one of my finest moments, which is also so crazy sounding. But what I mean by that is those two fancy behavioral economists, they actually, one of them is a wonderful mentor of mine and is a very dear friend. And the other I know very well as well. And so they both ended up being pretty instrumental mentors in my career. And I benefited so much. And I don't know. know that I don't know whether they, we would be this tight if they hadn't seen me share something vulnerable and also funny. It was funny. And I think that was, it was also maybe surprising to them because they're so used to having students kind of understandably be on their guard. And so it maybe made me stand out in a, in a way that ended up being a good, good thing. But it was, I'm not saying that I did this strategically. It was like a weird moment that I had that I think ended up paying off big time. I mean, in some ways, the choice that we often have in these moments is do we show vulnerability or do we aim for respectability?
一点也不。事实上，现在我认为这是我最精彩的时刻之一，这听起来也很疯狂。但我这样说是指，那两位厉害的行为经济学家，实际上，其中一位是我的良师益友，也是我非常亲密的朋友。另一位我也非常了解。所以他们最终都成了我职业生涯中非常关键的导师。我受益匪浅。而且我不知道。我不知道如果我们没有看到我分享一些既脆弱又有趣的事情，我们的关系还会不会这么紧密。这很有趣。而且我认为那也是，这对他们来说可能也是意料之外的，因为他们习惯了学生们出于可以理解的原因而有所防备。所以它也许让我脱颖而出，最终变成了一件好事。但我并不是说我是出于战略考虑才这样做的。这就像是我经历的一个奇怪的时刻，我认为它最终得到了巨大的回报。我的意思是，在某些情况下，我们在这些时刻经常面临的选择是，我们是表现出脆弱还是追求体面？
And I think many of us choose the latter. And what you're saying is that in the long run, at least, the former might be better. Precisely. In fact, I might even go so far as to say that that is a way to gain respect is by being vulnerable at the right time and the right place. and that happened to be, I think, the right time, the right place for me. But I think a key to becoming respectable can be actually vulnerability. And in fact, we've seen this when we've done lots of research with leaders of organizations where they've, we encourage them to be a little bit vulnerable, share a little bit about what they're like as a weakness,
我想我们中的许多人会选择后者。而你想说的是，至少从长远来看，前者可能会更好。确切地说。事实上，我甚至可以说，在正确的时间、正确的地点表现出脆弱，是赢得尊重的一种方式。而那恰好是我认为对我来说正确的时间、正确的地点。但我认为变得受人尊敬的一个关键实际上可以是脆弱。事实上，当我们对组织领导人进行大量研究时，我们看到了这一点，我们鼓励他们表现得有点脆弱，多分享一点他们作为弱点的一面，
if they say to their employees, I'm working a little bit on my public speaking. That actually makes the employees trust them more, be more willing to work for them. And it does not erode the leader's perceived competence. Yeah, you ran a study once, I believe, with executives at Google, where you basically said the executive either shares of vulnerability or hides it, and you ask people how they would respond to that executive. Exactly. Because one of the key challenges here is, you know, you're a leader.
如果他们对员工说，我正在努力提高我的公众演讲能力。这实际上会使员工更信任他们，更愿意为他们工作。而且这不会损害领导者在人们心目中的能力。是的，我记得你曾经在谷歌的高管中做过一项研究，你基本上让高管要么分享脆弱，要么隐藏脆弱，然后你问人们他们会如何回应那个高管。完全正确。因为这里的核心挑战之一是，你知道，你是一位领导者。
You don't want people to, you don't want to lessen their faith in you. You want them to be comfortable with you and trust you and respect you. and take your leadership. And so you do want people to view you as competent. That's really important. And the primary concern about being a little bit open about your weaknesses is that that's going to erode competence. So we put this to the test. And what we did was with this Google executive, we had him record a few different versions of a video where he introduced himself to people. And yeah, in one of the versions, he added this point that he had applied to like something like 20 different jobs before he landed this one. So that's revealing a failure. And what we found is, when the executive did that,
你不想让人们，你不想削弱他们对你的信心。你希望他们能和你在一起时感到自在、信任你、尊重你，并接受你的领导。所以你确实希望人们认为你有能力。这真的很重要。而对公开自己的弱点感到担忧的主要原因是，这会损害能力。所以我们对此进行了测试。我们做的是，在这个谷歌高管的配合下，让他录制了几个不同版本的视频，他在视频中向大家介绍自己。是的，在其中一个版本中，他补充了这样一点：在得到这份工作之前，他曾申请过大约20份不同的工作。所以这是在暴露一次失败。我们发现的是，当这位高管这样做时，
people trusted him more. They wanted to work for him more. And it did not erode his perceived competence. A couple of years ago, we had the Stanford psychiatrist Anna Lemke on Hidden Brain. She's an addiction researcher, and she talked very openly about an addiction of sorts that she developed in her 40s when she was already a well-established and well-respected professor and researcher. I want to play you a clip from that show, Leslie. I got to a point where whenever I wasn't doing something that I absolutely had to do, like for my work or my family, I was reading romance novels. Wow.
人们更信任他了。他们更渴望为他工作。并且这并没有损害他被认为具备的能力。几年前，我们在《隐藏的大脑》节目中请到了斯坦福大学的精神病学家安娜·莱姆克。她是一名成瘾研究人员，她非常坦率地谈到了她在40多岁时养成的一种类似成瘾的习惯，当时她已经是一位声名显赫、备受尊敬的教授和研究员。我想给你播放那期节目的一小段音频，莱斯利。我到了这样一个地步：每当我不用做那些我绝对必须做的事情时，比如为了工作或为了家庭，我都在读言情小说。哇。
And then it got to where, like, that's all I wanted to do. And I didn't enjoy anything else. I didn't even really want to, like, be with my kids or my husband, right? I just wanted those times to rush through them so that I could go back to reading romance novels. The other thing that I only realized in retrospect was that these sort of tamer versions of romance where, you know, the sex scenes aren't super graphic, well, those stop working for me. And now I needed ever more graphic types of romance novels in order to get that zing that I was looking for. So it may seem like Anna Lemke was embarrassing herself by revealing her fascination with romance novels and eventually with erotic fiction.
然后情况发展到，就像，那是我想做的全部事情。我不再享受任何其他事情。我甚至不想，比如，和我的孩子或丈夫在一起，对吧？我只是想快点度过那些时间，好让我能回去读言情小说。我只有在事后才意识到的另一件事是，这些比较温和的言情小说版本，你知道的，其中的性爱场面并不是超级露骨的那种，嗯，那些对我不起作用了。现在我需要更重口味、更露骨的言情小说，才能获得我一直在寻找的那种刺激。所以安娜·莱姆克通过透露她对言情小说以及后来的色情小说的着迷，似乎是在让自己出丑。
But those episodes of Hidden Brain that we devoted to her work remain among the most popular episodes in our history, Leslie. For listeners who are interested, they were titled The Paradox of Pleasure and The Path to Enough. But more important than that, I don't think anyone listened to that episode and thought less of Anna Lemke. All she heard in the feedback that she received and all that we heard was admiration for her courage and for herself insight. Yeah, totally. This is such a great example. And I think, you know, it's one thing to say that you're confident in yourself. It's another thing to model it. It's so much more powerful when you show it. And I think saying these things publicly owning it like that, saying like it's relatable, it's human. We shouldn't be so ashamed. We should be more upfront about these things we struggle with really took guts. And therefore, like we admire her for that because she's showing that she's a very competent, confident person because she has the guts to do this. It's also really relatable, right?
但莱斯利，我们专门为她的工作制作的那些《隐藏的大脑》节目仍然是我们历史上最受欢迎的节目之一。对于感兴趣的听众，它们的标题是《快乐的悖论》和《知足之路》。但比这更重要的是，我认为没有人听了那一集后会看低安娜·莱姆克。她在收到的所有反馈中听到的，以及我们听到的一切，都是对她的勇气和自我洞察力的钦佩。完全同意。这是一个非常好的例子。并且我认为，你知道，宣称自己充满自信是一回事，以身作则又是另一回事。当你展示出来时，它的力量要强大得多。而且我认为公开说出这些事情，像那样坦然承认，说这很有共鸣，很有人情味。我们不应该感到如此羞耻。我们应该对我们与之抗争的这些事情更加坦诚，这确实需要勇气。因此，就像我们钦佩她一样，因为她展现出她是一个非常能干、自信的人，因为她有勇气这样做。这也是引起共鸣的，对吧？
We all have, we may not struggle with the same things, but we all have things we struggle with. And so when you have someone, you know, a prestigious, I've really admired academic, we think of a typical academic as like really buttoned up. And then they show their human side. We think, oh, you know, they're just like us. And you really admire that. We've all been told to think before we speak, but what if revealing more than we intend, our awkward stories, our embarrassing mistakes, can actually draw people closer to us.
我们所有人都有，我们可能不会与同样的事情作斗争，但我们都有需要挣扎面对的事情。所以，当你有一个人，你知道的，一个声誉卓著、我非常钦佩的学者，我们认为典型的学者就像是那种非常保守、严谨的人。然后他们展示了自己人性的一面。我们会想，哦，你知道的，他们和我们一样。你会由衷地钦佩这一点。我们都被告知要在说话前先思考，但是如果我们透露的信息超出了我们的意图，比如我们尴尬的故事、令人难窘迫的错误，实际上可以拉近我们与他人的距离，会怎么样呢？
When we come back, the unexpected benefits of oversharing. You're listening to Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedantam. This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedantam. We all roll our eyes at people who share too much, the colleague who tells you in graphic detail about his upset stomach. the friend who gives you a blow-by-blow account of her recent colonoscopy. But have you noticed that over time, you come to see these people as more authentic than the people who keep their embarrassments to themselves?
广告回来后，我们将探讨过度分享的意外好处。欢迎收听《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。这里是《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。我们都会对那些分享过多的人翻白眼，比如那个向你详细描述他胃部不适的同事，那个向你事无巨细地讲述她最近做肠镜检查的朋友。但你有没有注意到，随着时间的推移，比起那些把尴尬藏在心里的人，你反而会觉得这些人更加真实？
At Harvard Business School, psychologist Leslie John studies how and why we often get self-disclosure wrong. Leslie, in our conversation last week, you talked about how we are all worried about sharing too much information, TMI, but not enough about the risks of sharing TLI, too little information. You talked about how we persistently underestimate the value and the power of self-disclosure. One of those benefits is that sharing information simply feels good. What have neurobiologists learned about the rewards of self-disclosure? Oh, yeah, this is so cool, this research. So led by Diana Tamir, she and her co-author found that opening up, revealing things about
在哈佛商学院，心理学家莱斯利·约翰研究了我们如何以及为什么常常在自我披露这件事上出错。莱斯利，在上周的对话中，你谈到我们都如何担心分享过多信息（TMI），而对分享过少信息（TLI）的风险关注不够。你谈到我们一直低估了自我披露的价值和力量。其中一个好处是，分享信息本身就感觉很好。神经生物学家对自我披露的回报有什么发现？哦，是的，这项研究太酷了。在黛安娜·塔米尔的领导下，她和她的合著者发现，敞开心扉、揭示关于
ourselves, self-disclosure is pleasurable. And she showed that you can see this at the neuron level in the brain. So what they did was they put people into brain scanners. They asked them questions about themselves. And what they found was that when the people got personal questions, the pleasure areas of their brain lit up, so to speak, were activated, much more than those who did not get to talk about themselves. And in some ways, this correlates with our behavioral experience of wanting to be seen, of having the pleasure of feeling like we are seen by someone. Completely.
我们自己的事情，即自我披露，是令人愉悦的。她表明，你可以在大脑的神经元水平上看到这一点。所以他们做的是，他们把人们放入脑部扫描仪中。他们问他们关于他们自己的问题。他们发现，当人们被问到个人问题时，他们大脑的快乐区域就会亮起，可以说是被激活了，远比那些不能谈论自己的人要活跃得多。在某些情况下，这与我们希望被看见的行为体验、获得那种被某人看见的快乐体验相呼应。完全是这样。
I mean, that's one of the great joys of intimate relationships is that if you really share and keep sharing, you are really, really known and seen by someone for exactly who you are. And that gives us so much relief, but also joy. There's also some interesting work showing that people. People like when their spouses see them as they are rather than exaggeratedly positive. So suppose you have low self-esteem, you actually will feel more secure and heard and comfortable in your relationship if your spouse recognizes that you have low self-esteem rather than if your spouse says, oh, you've got great self-esteem. So even when they're kind of unflattering things about ourselves, we would much rather our partner know us for who we are. And that's really the beauty of close relationships, is the joy that that brings.
我的意思是，亲密关系的最大乐趣之一就是，如果你真正分享并不断分享，你就会真正地、真正地被某人了解和看到，看到你最真实的样子。这给我们带来了极大的安慰，也带来了快乐。还有一些有趣的研究表明，人们喜欢伴侣按照他们本来的样子看待他们，而不是给予夸张的正面评价。假设你的自尊心较低，如果你伴侣承认你自尊心较低，而不是说“哦，你的自尊心很强”，你实际上会感到在关系中更有安全感、被倾听和舒适。因此，即使是关于我们自身的那些不太光彩的事情，我们也更愿意让伴侣了解真实的我们。这确实是亲密关系的美妙之处，也是它带来的快乐。
Having someone who knows everything about you is just wonderful. I understand that you recently told your colleagues about a small but embarrassing fact about something that you did in the shower. It's a decision that might be hard to explain other than you just felt like sharing it. What did you tell them, Leslie? Yeah, I don't even remember the actual context. But what I told them was that the smell of the smell of. the body shop Satsuma soap, you know, the bar soap, it's this really juicy orange smell. It smelled so real to me that I took a giant bite out of it.
有一个了解你一切的人真是太棒了。据我所了解，你最近向你的同事讲述了你在浴室里做过的一件虽小但很尴尬的事。这个决定可能很难解释，除了你当时只是想分享它。你对他们说了什么，莱斯利？是的，我甚至不记得当时的具体语境了。但我告诉他们的是，那个The Body Shop（美体小铺）的萨津果（Satsuma）香皂的气味，你知道，就是那种块状肥皂，它有一种非常浓郁的橙子香味。它闻起来太真实了，以至于我狠狠地咬了一大口。
And I was well above the age of six when I did that. What was the reaction of your colleagues when you told him this? Oh, they laughed. It was colleagues that I was already friends with, so I knew it would be. It wasn't like the super stiff upper lip kind of colleagues, although I did have a very stiff upper lip boss once, and I cried in front of him, and that was interesting. But not undermining, as I thought it would be.
我做这件事的时候远不止六岁。当你告诉你的同事这件事时，他们的反应是什么？哦，他们笑了。那是和我已经是朋友的同事，所以我知道会是这样。那不是那种超级死板的同事，尽管我确实曾有过一个非常古板的老板，我在他面前哭过，那很有趣。但并没有像我想象的那样损害我的形象。
He ended up really helping me in promotions, so maybe that benefited me too. You once conducted a study in which you analyzed data from a professional social networking platform. What did you find about the power of disclosures, Leslie? Yeah, so we got data from a large social networking site, a professional one, and we were able to get people's posts and then how many responses, positive responses, likes they got and so on. And what we found was that the posts that got more likes were the ones that shared something a little bit edgy or vulnerable or real. And, you know, it kind of goes in contrast to this idea that we should present a curated portrait of ourselves all the time, like how we present ourselves on LinkedIn.
他最后真的在晋升方面帮了我大忙，所以这可能也对我有利。你曾经做过一项研究，分析了来自一个专业社交网络平台的数据。关于披露的力量，你发现了什么，莱斯利？是的，所以我们从一个大型社交网络网站（一个专业网站）获取了数据，我们能够获取人们的帖子，然后了解他们获得了多少回应、正面回应、点赞等等获得情况。我们发现，获得更多点赞的帖子是那些分享了一些有点前卫、脆弱或真实内容的帖子。而且，你知道，这与那种我们应该时刻呈现精心策划的个人形象的想法形成了对比，就像我们在领英上展示自己的方式一样。
This was a different platform. And so that was interesting. And it spurred many follow-up experiments where we had leaders reveal something a little bit more than what they think they should reveal, like saying something that they're working on. They're working on their organizational skills or something. And then we measured employees. trust in them, motivation, and so on. And we found positive results there. And do you think this is about people who reveal themselves being seen as more authentic? Yes, absolutely. In fact, that was the key driver of the effects. And I think it makes sense if you think of like people that are high status, leaders in organizations, the queen. You can think of all kinds of people, not just in our work lives, but in the world that are really high status, movie stars maybe even, when we know something really relatable about them, they seem more real to us. They're more authentic, and we really like that. They're not just kind of these aloof people that are out of touch.
这是一个不同的平台。所以这很有趣。它促成了许多后续实验，我们让领导者透露一些比他们认为自己应该透露的更多的事情，比如谈论他们正在努力改进的事情。他们正在努力提高自己的组织能力之类的。然后我们测量了员工对他们的信任度、积极性等等。我们在那里发现了积极的结果。你认为这是因为那些展露自我的人被视为更真实吗？是的，绝对是。事实上，那是产生这些影响的关键驱动因素。我认为这讲得通，如果你想想那些地位崇高的人、组织中的领导者、女王。你可以想到各种各样的人，不仅仅是在我们的工作生活中，而且在世界上地位很高的人，甚至可能是电影明星，当我们了解一些关于他们的非常接地气的事情时，他们对我们来说就显得更真实了。他们更真实，我们真的很喜欢这一点。他们不仅仅是那种高高在上、脱离群众的人。
We like people when we can relate to them. So it makes us like them and trust them. It's maybe even why things like one of my guilty pleasures is gossip magazines. So Us Weekly has a section called Stars. They're just like us, and it'll be like, Gwyneth Paltrow will be sitting and drinking a coffee. And I love that section. And I think part of it is because it's just, you know, you see these people in the movies and you kind of have them on a pedestal. And then it's really refreshing to see them just be normal.
当我们可以与他们产生共鸣时，我们就会喜欢他们。所以这让我们喜欢并信任他们。这也许就是为什么像八卦杂志这样的东西成为我的某种罪恶快感（Guilty Pleasure）。比如《美国周刊》（Us Weekly）有一个栏目叫“明星。他们就像我们一样”，里面会刊登格温妮丝·帕特罗坐在那儿喝咖啡之类的照片。我非常喜欢那个栏目。我想部分原因是因为，你知道的，你在电影里看到这些人，你会把他们捧上神坛。然后看到他们只是做回普通人，真的让人耳目一新。
I'm wondering if this might also be part of the appeal of someone like Donald Trump. You know, he has lots of edges. He can be sometimes crass. But even the people who dislike him or disagree with his policies often feel like what you see is what you get. Yes, yes. I mean, he's a very complex character. I do think that part of the appeal is that he has this reputation for being kind of a straight shooter. And he does say unpopular things, and he's not shy about it.
我想知道这是否也是像唐纳德·特朗普这样的人吸引力的一部分。你知道的，他有很多棱角。他有时会显得有些粗俗。但即使是那些不喜欢他或不同意他政策的人，也经常觉得所见即所得。是的，是的。我的意思是，他是一个非常复杂的人物。我确实认为，部分吸引力在于他有一种直言不讳的名声。而且他确实会说一些不受欢迎的话，他也并不为此感到羞怯。
A lot of us may disagree with them, but at the end of the day, the fact that he's saying unpopular things is kind of refreshing because we're so used to politicians just being politicians. and it's like nauseating because we're like, just tell me, tell me the real thing. And so I think that might be part of his appeal. But he is a very complex character and there's a lot going on there. So many prominent people go to great lengths to conceal things about themselves, but they don't always see the consequences of this secrecy. Tell me what happened, Leslie, when Princess Diana died in 1997 and the Queen of England was called upon to respond.
我们中的许多人可能不同意他的观点，但归根结底，他说出不受欢迎的话这一事实有点让人耳目一新，因为我们太习惯了政客只是表现得像个政客。这让人感到恶心，因为我们会想：直接告诉我，告诉我真实的想法。所以我认为这可能是他吸引力的一部分。但他是一个非常复杂的人物，其中有很多门道。许多知名人士竭力隐瞒自己的事情，但他们并不总是能预见到这种保密带来的后果。莱斯利，请告诉我，当1997年戴安娜王妃去世、英国女王被要求做出回应时，发生了什么？
Yeah, this is another one of these flashball memories. She's as a good Canadian. I love the monarchy. And I remember waking up that morning when Diana died, my mother woke me up and she just said she's dead and everyone was devastated. So Queen Elizabeth, the monarchy, is very stoic in their personality, right? And they're very private. So it's very unusual for them to open up about anything personal. And when Princess Diana died in 1997. The queen, she was really, she was criticized in the first week because she seemed really cold. In fact, for the first week, she hadn't been seen in public. She was staying cloistered in the family's baromoral estate, which was far from the crowds, but the crowds were saying, show us you care, speak to us. And so then finally, about a week later, she did something very uncharacteristic, but I think really brave and really wonderful. She addressed the nation in a live and heartfelt address. She was in Buckingham,
是的，这也是这些标志性记忆之一。作为一个优秀的加拿大人，我热爱君主制。我记得戴安娜去世的那天早上醒来，我母亲把我叫醒，她只是说她死了，所有人都悲痛欲绝。所以伊丽莎白女王和王室，他们的性格非常坚忍，对吧？而且他们非常注重隐私。因此，他们对任何私事敞开心扉是非常罕见的。1997年戴安娜王妃去世时。女王，她真的，在第一周她受到了批评，因为她显得真的很冷漠。事实上，在第一周里，她没有在公众面前露面。她一直深居简出地呆在王室的巴尔莫勒尔庄园里，这里远离人群，但群众却在说：让我们看到你在乎，对我们说说话。所以最后，大约一周后，她做了一件非常不符合她性格的事，但我认为非常勇敢，也非常精彩。她通过电视直播发表了一场发自内心的对全国的讲话。她当时在白金汉，
Pal, she stood in front of a window where you could see right outside the window, the flowers and the morning crowds. It was really visceral. And she started by saying, she said, since last Sunday's dreadful news we have seen throughout Britain and around the world, an overwhelming expression of sadness at Diana's death. We've all been trying in our different ways to cope. It is not easy to express a sense of loss since the initial shock is often succeeded by a mixture of other feelings, disbelief, incomprehension, anger. And now this is extremely uncharacteristic of the queen, right? To open up, period, let alone talk about all these emotions. That was extremely uncharacteristic. She went on then to say, this week at Balmoral, we have all
宫，她站在一扇窗前，透过窗户可以直接看到外面的鲜花和哀悼的人群。这非常直观。她开场说道，她说：“自上周日听到这个可怕的消息以来，我们在英国各地和全世界都看到了对戴安娜去世的如潮般的悲痛之情。我们都在用各自不同的方式努力应对。要表达失落感并不容易，因为最初的震惊之后往往伴随着各种其他情绪：难以置信、不可理解、愤怒。”现在，这极其不符合女王的性格，对吧？敞开心扉暂且不论，更不用说谈论所有这些情绪了。这极其不符合她的性格。她接着说道：“本周在巴尔莫勒尔，我们都在
been trying to help William and Harry come to terms with the devastating loss that they and the rest of us have suffered. And so she was saying, I'm being a proper grandmother. I am being with my grandchildren. And that is more important than being a queen right now. And people loved her. for it. Like when she revealed, you know, in a reserved way, but for her, like in that context, that was a big reveal. People celebrated it and they felt like it helped them mourn, too, knowing that. So it's a paradox because we often think that being vulnerable exposes us and makes us appear weak when it's often the opposite. Exactly. And now, of course, the message isn't we should always share everything to everyone. Like it is a risky, but I think it's
努力帮助威廉和哈利接受他们以及我们其余人所遭受的毁灭性损失。”所以她是在说：我正在做一个称职的祖母。我和我的孙子们在一起。此时此刻，这比做一个女王更重要。人们为她而倾倒。就像当她展现出（虽然是以一种保守的方式，但对她而言，在那种背景下，那是一个重大的表露）时。人们对此庆祝，并且他们觉得这帮助他们也进行了哀悼，因为知道了这一点。所以这是一个悖论，因为我们经常认为表现出脆弱会让我们暴露无遗，让我们显得软弱，而事实往往恰恰相反。完全正确。现在，当然，传达的信息并不是我们应该随时随地向所有人分享一切。这确实是一件有风险的事，但我认为正是
It's precisely because it's risky that makes the reward so great. Because when you think about it, the best way to earn trust is to earn it, right? And how do you earn trust? You signal it by being vulnerable, making yourself vulnerable to someone. By doing that, you're saying to someone implicitly, hey, I trust you to not take advantage of me, right? It's like it's very common in the animal kingdom. It's when puppies reveal their bellies.
因为有风险，回报才如此巨大。因为仔细想想，赢得信任的最佳方式就是去赢得它，对吧？你如何赢得信任？你通过展现脆弱、让自己在某人面前变得脆弱来发出信号。通过这样做，你是在含蓄地对某人说：嘿，我信任你，相信你不会利用我，对吧？这在动物界非常普遍。就像小狗露出它们的肚皮一样。
It's like a sensitive part and they're garnering trust that way. Even octopuses, which are characteristically kind of loners, they have a way of wrapping their tentacles to signal that they're open and to show that their trust to make themselves vulnerable. Even the handshake. The handshake among humans originated by showing that you have to exposing your hand to show that you're not armed. So all of these things, the way you get trust and respect is often by showing it instead of saying you can trust me.
这就像是一个敏感部位，它们以此来建立信任。甚至章鱼，它们天性中通常有点独来独往，它们有一种用触手缠绕的方式来发出自己很开放的信号，并展示它们的信任，使自己变得脆弱。甚至连握手。人类之间的握手起源于展示你的手，暴露出你的手以表明你没有武装。所以所有这些事情，你获得信任和尊重的方式往往是通过展示它，而不是说你可以信任我。
You yourself demonstrated a moment of authenticity when you were interviewing for a job at Harvard. Now, the Harvard Business School is a notoriously tough place, lots of big egos, competitive people. Set the scene for me and tell me what happened, Leslie. Yeah. So I went into the room, the interview. room and I was very nervous because I never in the world imagined I'd be in a position where I actually had a shot at a Harvard job, but here I was. And I knew I had a shot at it because one of my mentors who was at the peeing incident, the embarrassing story, he, I knew that he had like,
你自己也展现了一个展现真实的时刻，当时你正在面试哈佛大学的工作。现在，哈佛商学院是一个出了名的艰难地方，有很多自负的人、竞争激烈的人。请为我还原一下当时的场景，告诉我发生了什么，莱斯利。好的。我走进了房间，面试。房间里，我非常紧张，因为我做梦也没想到自己有一天会获得一个有机会进入哈佛工作的职位，但我就在这里。我知道我有机会，因为我的一个导师，也就是那个尿裤子事件、那个尴尬故事的见证者，我知道他，
he had stuck his neck out for me. And he had really spent social capital on saying that I'm legit. And so I get there. I'm really nervous. And when I, nervous. Sometimes I blurt out stupid things. And so I sat there and it's all men, which makes it even more intimidating for me. And one of the faculty members looked at my CV and he said, oh, you used to be a ballet dancer because I was trained as a ballet dancer. He says, you used to be a ballet dancer. You know, I was a dancer too. And he was clearly trying to make a joke and trying to have a moment of levity because he saw that I was nervous. Like it was incredibly kind what he was trying to do. But that didn't register on me in the moment. In the moment, for some strange reason, I decided
他为我冒了风险。他真的投入了社会资本，说我是合法的、有实力的。所以我到了那里。我真的很紧张。当我，紧张时。有时我会脱口而出一些蠢话。所以我坐在那里，全都是男性，这让我感到更加恐吓。其中一位教员看了看我的简历，他说：“哦，你以前是个芭蕾舞演员？”因为我受过芭蕾舞演员的训练。他说：“你以前是个芭蕾舞演员？你知道的，我也是个舞者。”他显然是在开玩笑，试图活跃一下气氛，因为他看到我很紧张。他试图做的事情真是太善良了。但这并没有在我脑海中留下深刻印象。在那一刻，出于某种奇怪的原因，我决定
it would be a good idea to go ahead and look him up and down and then cock my head and say, clearly, really sarcastic tone. Oh my gosh. Wow. And as soon as I said that, yeah, I was like, oh my God, what did I just do? It's like I just poured gasoline all over myself and lit a match. Please can I take that back? My face turned bright red and my mentor then he tried to break it up by he's like, let's get you a glass of water and kind of reset that way. But I just thought I'm never going to get this job. Well, it turned out that I did end up getting the job. And then the guy I insulted, he's so sweet.
上下打量他一番，然后歪着头，用一种极其讽刺的语气说“真的吗，显然如此”是个好主意。哦，天哪。哇。就在我刚说完这句话，是的，我就想：哦，天哪，我刚刚做了什么？就好像我刚把自己全身浇满汽油并划了根火柴。请问我能收回刚才的话吗？我的脸变得通红，然后我的导师试图打圆场，他说：“让我们给你倒杯水吧”，并以此重新开始。但我当时就想，我绝对拿不到这份工作了。嗯，事实证明，我最后确实得到了这份工作。然后那个被我羞辱的家伙，他太好了。
He ended up being a close mentor and friend. And he said he loved to tell the story, regale job candidates and say, you know, when Leslie insulted me like that, we thought, hey, she's sassy. She'll fit right in here. She's a jerk like guys, just like us. So I got lucky. I got lucky. That was definitely not strategic.
他最终成为了我的密友和导师。他说他很喜欢讲这个故事，用来取悦求职者并说：“你知道吗，当莱斯利那样羞辱我时，我们想，嘿，她很有个性。她会很适合这里的。她和我们一样是个直率的家伙。”所以我很幸运。我很幸运。这绝对不是出于策略。
But the bigger point, I think, is that job interviews are super high stakes, right? And the norm there is to only present our best foot forward. And we should be very careful about any kind of vulnerability in these high-stakes context. But still, there is space for a little bit of levity, a little bit of sass, a little bit of authenticity, whatever your blend of that is. And the reason is that provided you're qualified for the job, if you show a bit of yourself like that, one, you stand out more, you're more memorable. And two, it helps you, you can see how they respond to you, and it helps you get a sense
但更重要的一点是，我认为求职面试的利害关系非常高，对吧？那里的常态是只展示我们最好的一面。在这些高风险的环境中，我们应该对任何形式的脆弱保持非常谨慎。不过，仍然有空间容纳一点轻松、一点个性、一点真实，无论你对这些的融合比例是怎样的。原因在于，只要你胜任这份工作，如果你能稍微展现出这样真实的自己，第一，你会更显眼，让人印象更深刻。第二，这能帮你，你可以看到他们对你的反应，这有助于你了解他们的文化，以及你的个性是否契合。你能在那里蓬勃发展吗？这是一个很好的小测试。莱斯利，自我披露的另一个好处是，它可以促使其他人做出回应，也披露一些事情。谈谈这种自我披露的互惠性质。是的。所以当向你敞开心扉，说一些稍微脆弱的话时，我几乎可以肯定地说这是一种本能。你知道，这是一个沉重的词。但这确实是我们人类非常自然的一件事情，那就是礼尚往来，做出相应的回应。这意味着我们倾向于也有一种冲动，去回敬一些同样敏感的事情。
of their culture and whether your personality fits. Are you going to thrive there? That's a, it's a good little test. One other advantage of self-disclosure, Leslie, is that it can prompt other people to disclose things in response. Talk about this reciprocal nature of self-disclosure. Yes. So when someone opens up to you, says something slightly vulnerable, I'm almost comfortable with saying it's an instinct. You know, that's a heavy word. But it's a very natural thing we humans do is to reciprocate, to respond in kind. And what that means is that we tend to feel the urge to also reveal something of similar sensitivity back.
这种冲动是如此强烈，以至于我的同事杨美月（Youngme Moon）曾做过一项迷人的研究。她是前不久做的，但这属于那种经久不衰的发现之一，她基本上表明，互惠的冲动是如此强烈，以至于我们甚至对无生命的物体——计算机——也会这样做。所以她让一台计算机，她让参与者坐在计算机前，计算机输出了一段文本，上面写着（它甚至没有说“我”，它甚至没有试图拟人化自己），它只是说：“这台计算机很少发挥其全部潜力。它很少能用满硬盘”或者类似的话，这有点像。就像电脑在向你倾诉一样，对吧？
So strong is this urge that a colleague of mine, Young Me Moon, has done a fascinating study. She did it a while back, but it's one of these kind of ever-grimmy. green findings where she basically showed that the urge to reciprocate is so strong that we even do it with inanimate objects with computers. So she had a computer, if she had participants sitting at a computer and the computer output the text that said, it didn't even say I, it wasn't even trying to personify itself. It just said, this computer rarely reaches its full potential. It rarely gets to use its full hard drive or something like that, which is kind of. Kind of like the computer's disclosing to you, right?
然后他们进行了测量，人们随后向电脑吐露了关于他们自己正在苦恼的事情，或者他们觉得没有发挥全部潜力的某种方式。这真的很神奇。据我所了解，莱斯利，你会在课堂上做一个练习，让学生们互相提问。你设置这个练习的方式有一个转折。请告诉我你是怎么做的，又有什么发现。是的。所以我把教室分成两半，我对每个人说：等一下，你们会有一个问题，你们将与身旁的人讨论几分钟。但我只向每个组透露一个问题。所以一组得到的问题是：“你喜欢你工作的什么地方？”就像，超级无聊的问题。另一组在第一组不知情的情况下，得到的问题是：“你上一次哭是什么时候？”通常当我把这个问题抛出来时，会有人发出叹气声。
And so then they measured, and people then revealed back to the computer about something that they were struggling with or something, a way that they feel they hadn't reached their full potential. It's really amazing. I understand that you conduct a classroom exercise, Leslie, where you ask students to pose questions to one another. There's a twist in the way that you set up the exercise. Tell me what you do and what you find. Yes. So I divide the room into two and I say to everyone, in a moment, you're going to have a question that you're going to talk about for a few minutes with the person next to you. But I only reveal one question to each group. So one group gets the question, what do you like about your job? Like ww-want-wom, super boring question. The other group, unbeknownst to the first group, gets the question, when is the last time you cried? And usually when I give that question out, someone's going to make an audible groan.
就像，人们不想谈论他们上一次哭是什么时候。事实上，我的好闺蜜艾莉森·布鲁克斯（Alison Brooks）做了很多关于对话和话题的研究，她让人对“你想谈论什么话题”与“不想谈论什么话题”进行排名或排序。而谈论“你上一次哭是什么时候”一直稳居倒数第一。然而，当我强迫人们时，凭借作为教授赋予我的权力。当我强迫全班讨论这个话题时，他们反而是那些情绪高涨的人。
Like, people do not want to talk about the last time they cried. In fact, my bestie Alison Brooks has done, she does lots of work on conversation and topics, and she's gotten people to rank or order like what topics do you want to talk about versus not. And talking about the last time you cried consistently ranks dead last. And yet, when I force people, by the powers bestowed on me as a prof. When I force the class to talk about it, they're the ones that are bubbling.
他们反而是那些真正快乐、兴奋、感兴趣和受感动的人。你能在教室里感受到这一点。一侧的能量惊人，而另一侧则相当平淡。从某种程度上说，这印证了这个悖论，对吧，莱斯利？也就是说，我们在某些方面非常犹豫不愿分享，但一旦我们开始这样做，
They're the ones that are actually joyful and excited and interested and moved. You can feel it in the classroom. The energy on one side is amazing and the other side is pretty flat. And in some ways it speaks to the paradox, right, Leslie, which is that in some ways we hesitate so much to share, but the moment we start to do it,
它有很多方面都让人感觉很好。完全正确。这就是为什么我认为关键在于，你不能只谈论分享。你必须去行动，因为眼见为实。就像实践出真知一样。你必须亲身体验到这些好处，才能真正迷恋上其中的可能性。你刚才提到了你的同事艾莉森·伍德布鲁克斯。不久前，我们在《隐藏的大脑》节目中请到了艾莉森。
There's so many aspects of it that feel good. Exactly. And that's why I think a key thing is you can't just talk about sharing. You've got to do it because seeing is believing. Like doing it is believing. You've got to feel the benefits in order to kind of get hooked on the possibilities. You mentioned your colleague, Alison Woodbrooks, a second ago. We had Allison on Hidden Brain some time ago.
你和艾莉森当然是朋友。但你们俩最近向对方做了一个重要的披露。这个披露是什么？是的，一想到这个我就会起鸡皮疙瘩。所以我们曾邀请一位学者来我们的实验室谈论他的研究，正好是关于竞争意识和嫉妒的，他列举了导致人们产生竞争心理的原因，比如相似性、好胜心、成就导向、才华，而艾莉森和我全程都在眉目传情，仿佛在说：这不就是我们吗？这不就是我们吗？
You and Allison, of course, are friends. But the two of you recently made a significant disclosure to one another. What was this disclosure? Yeah, so I'm getting goosebumps thinking about this. So we had invited a scholar to come to talk to our lab about his research, and it happened to be about rivalry and envy, and he was going through the things that caused people to feel rivalry with each other, and it was like similarity, competitiveness, achievement-oriented, talent, and Allison and I are just banking eyes throughout the whole thing like, this is this us? This is us?
所以当我们走回办公室时，她挑起了这个话题，因为她正如我所说，是一位世界级的对话高手。她说：“我们为什么不是竞争对手？”这是一个非常棒的切入点，对吧？因为她说话的方式，她本可以问：“我们是竞争对手吗？感觉我们像是竞争对手。”但她将其框定为：“我们为什么不是竞争对手？”然后我们就进行了一次非常精彩的对话，关于（我说）：“是的，我承认有时我确实对你感到有点嫉妒。这主要是钦佩，但有时确实是嫉妒。”她说：“是的，我懂。有时我也会有那种感觉”，她用那种冷静如黄瓜、温暖如毛衣的方式表达，那是她特有的方式，而且也带有一种若无其事。她说：“是的，有时我也会有那种感觉。”但它让我们走得更近了。再次强调，承认这种觉得产生嫉妒似乎有点不合社交礼仪的事情——她是我最好的朋友之一——真的让我们更加亲密。这确实表明了，即使当你和某人很亲密时，
And so as we walk back to our offices, she broaches the topic because she's, as I said, world-class conversationalist. She says, why aren't we rivals? Which was an amazing entryway in, right? Because the way she said, she could have said, are we rivals? It feels like we're rivals. But she framed it as, why aren't we rivals? and and then we just had this wonderful conversation about how, you know, I said, yeah, I admit that
所以当我们走回办公室时，她提起了这个话题，因为正如我所说，她是一流的谈话高手。她说，我们为什么不是竞争对手呢？这是一个绝妙的切入点，对吧？因为她说话的方式，她本可以问，我们是对手吗？感觉我们像是对手。但她将其表述为，我们为什么不是竞争对手呢？然后我们进行了一场精彩的对话，关于，你知道的，我说，是的，我承认
sometimes I do feel a bit envious of you. It's mostly admiration, but sometimes it's envy. And she said, yeah, I hear you. Sometimes I feel that way too in this kind of cool as a cucumber, warm as a sweater way, which is her way, and kind of nonchalant to. Yeah, I feel that way too sometimes. but it just brought us so much closer. Again, like admitting this thing that's kind of a faux pot to feel envy about, like, she's one of my very best friends. And that really brought us even closer. And it's really an indicator of how even when you're close with someone,
有时我确实对你感到有点嫉妒。主要是钦佩，但有时也是嫉妒。她说，是的，我懂你的意思。有时我也有这种感觉，她那种冷静沉着、温暖贴切的方式，这也是她的一贯风格，显得很漫不经心。是的，有时我也有这种感觉。但这让我们拉近了许多距离。再说一次，就像承认这种事情在某种程度上算是一种失礼，因为感到嫉妒而感到失礼——她是我最好的朋友之一。这确实让我们更加亲密。这实际上表明了，即使你和某人很亲密，
a moment of authenticity, a moment of vulnerability, can actually bring you even closer. Yeah, completely. Revealing what's really on our minds means taking a chance. We might be laughed at, we might be scorned, or we might find ourselves drawn closer to the people we care about. When we come back, advise on how to engage in skillful self-disclosure. You're listening to Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam.
展现真实，表现脆弱，其实能拉近你们的距离。完全如此。袒露我们内心的真实想法意味着要承担风险。我们可能会被嘲笑，可能会被轻视，或者我们可能会发现自己与关心的人贴得更近了。稍后回来，我们将为您支招，教你如何进行巧妙的自我袒露。您正在收听的是《隐藏的大脑》。我是香卡·维丹塔姆。
This is Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedanta. Can you think of a time in your life when you came clean about a secret to someone else? How did they respond and how did you feel afterwards? If you are willing to share your personal story with a hidden brain audience or have a question or comment about self-concealment and self-disclosure, please find a very quiet room and record a voice memo on your phone. Two or three minutes is plenty. Email the file to us at Feedback at Hiddenbrain.org.
这里是《隐藏的大脑》。我是香卡·维丹塔姆。你能想起生活中什么时候曾向别人坦白过一个秘密吗？他们是如何反应的？事后你感觉如何？如果你愿意与《隐藏的大脑》听众分享你的个人故事，或者对隐瞒自我和自我袒露有任何疑问或评论，请找一个非常安静的房间，在手机上录制一段语音备忘录。两三分钟就足够了。请将文件发送至我们的邮箱：Feedback@hiddenbrain.org。
Use the subject line, secrets. Again, that's Feedback at Hiddenbrain.org. Theologist Leslie John is the author of Revealing, The Underrated Power of Oversharing. Leslie, a social scientist you know at Cornell University once posted a very unusual resume. It wasn't a list of important jobs and fancy publications. He called it a CV of failures. Tell me his story. Yeah, this is cool.
请使用主题词：秘密。再次强调，邮箱是Feedback@hiddenbrain.org。学者莱斯利·约翰是《袒露：过度分享的被低估的力量》一书的作者。莱斯利，你认识的一位康奈尔大学的社会科学家曾发布过一份非常寻常的简历。那不是一份列满重要工作和高档出版物的清单。他称之为失败履历。能讲讲他的故事吗？好的，这个很酷。
So what he did was he posted a CV that included not just all the fancy journals he had published. and all of his accomplishments, but also the failures. So for the journal articles that ended up being published, he also indicated the places that had rejected that article, that writing first. And this is highly anomalous, right? We never put failures in a CD, but he did. And it was really wonderful because I think it really had a wonderful effect
他做的是，他发布了一份简历，其中不仅包括他发表的所有高档期刊以及他所有的成就，还包括失败经历。因此，对于最终发表的期刊文章，他还指出了最初拒绝该文章、该作品的地方。这非常异常，对吧？我们从不在简历中写失败，但他写了。这真的很棒，因为我认为它确实产生了很好的效果
on more junior scholars to not feel so alone. because, you know, when you're a junior scholar, you don't see all the things, the failed experiments, and you don't see all the failed journal submissions. And so to see that someone who is super successful also has failed is really motivating, actually. If you're in a rut, you think, oh, well, he failed too. In a similar way, there's a woman by the name of Melanie Stefan. I think she's a neuroscientist, and she found out one day that her grant was rejected. But on that same day, the super famous football player, soccer player, Ronaldinho,
让资历较浅的学者感到不那么孤单。因为，你知道，当你是一名初级学者时，你不会看到所有的东西，那些失败的实验，你也不会看到所有被拒稿的期刊投稿。所以看到一个超级成功的人也经历过失败，其实真的很励志。如果你陷入困境，你会想，哦，好吧，他也失败了。以类似的方式，有一位名叫梅兰妮·斯特凡的女士。我想她是一位神经科学家，她有一天发现自己的资助申请被拒绝了。但在同一天，超级著名的足球运动员罗纳尔迪尼奥，
it was announced that he didn't make the World Cup team. And so for her, what she thought was, oh, I'm just like Ronaldino. Even Ronaldino fails sometimes, and it perked her up. I mean, in some ways, this brings us to what an economist might call a positive externality of disclosure. You know, when someone posts a CV of failures, it almost becomes easier for everyone else to talk about their challenges. Yeah, yeah, exactly. However, I think there's, it's really important, again, to read the room and understand where you are and understand what context you're in. So the CV example, this is someone who has already made it in academia,
有消息称他没有入选世界杯阵容。所以对她来说，她的想法是，哦，我简直就像罗纳尔迪尼奥。连罗纳尔迪尼奥有时也会失败，这让她振作了起来。我的意思是，在某些方面，这让我们想到了经济学家可能称之为自我袒露的积极外部性。你知道，当有人发布失败履历时，几乎会让其他人更容易谈论他们面临的挑战。对，对，完全如此。然而，我认为，同样重要的是，要看人脸色行事，了解你身处的环境，了解你所处的语境。所以简历的例子，这是一个已经在学术界站稳脚跟的人，
right? He's already got a great job. He's already a professor. I would not advise a doctoral candidate going on the rookie job market. I would not advise them to do this because your competence is kind of still in question there is particularly effective and less risky for someone who is already high status to do this. I want to ask you about a couple of disclosure dilemmas that you've experienced in your own life, Leslie. You recently worked through one that involved who received credit for a joint project. Tell me the story of what happened.
对吧？他已经有了一份不错的工作。他已经是教授了。我不建议刚进入就业市场的博士候选人这样做。我不建议他们这样做，因为你的能力在那里面临着质疑，对于已经有较高地位的人来说，这样做尤其有效且风险较小。莱斯利，我想问你关于你在自己生活中经历过的几个袒露困境。你最近处理过一个涉及谁应该为一个合作项目署名的困境。请讲讲发生了什么事。
Yes. So I was working with a team of co-authors, which is one of the great joys of my job. as I get to choose who I work with. And we had to fill out some paperwork for the article we were publishing. And one of the things was you had to write down which author gets the lion's share of credit for different aspects, one of them being idea generation. And I had gotten a draft of the filled out form from a co-author, and my heart kind of sank when I got it because she had written for the idea part.
好的。当时我和一个合作作者团队一起工作，这是我工作中的一大乐趣，因为我可以选择和谁合作。我们必须为我们要发表的文章填写一些表格。其中一项是，你必须写明哪位作者对不同的方面做出了主要贡献，其中之一就是想法的产生。我收到了合作者填好的表格草案，当我收到时，我的心有点沉了下去，因为她在想法那一栏写着：
She said equal contribution, all authors. And that stung for me because I knew where the idea had come from. I knew that it had come from me because I knew the specific motivating real-world thing that we built this paper on, which was something I had experienced. And so I knew that I had the kernel and that really bothered me. But, you know, my natural thing to do here would be to not say anything, would be to not rock the boat because, you know, I really love my co-authors and I value our relationship. and I don't want them to feel bad. I don't want them to think I'm petty. Nobody's going to read this,
她写的是：所有作者共同贡献。这让我感到刺痛，因为我知道这个主意是从哪里来的。我知道它来自我，因为我知道我们写这篇论文所依据的具体现实生活中的动因，那是我经历过的事情。所以我知道我掌握了核心，这真的很困扰我。但是，你知道，我在这里的自然反应是什么都不说，是不去破坏现状，因为，你知道，我真的很喜欢我的合作作者，我很珍视我们的关系，我不想让他们感到难过。我不想让他们觉得我很小气。没有人会去读这个，
the stupid credit lines. Like, it doesn't matter. Just go with it. But, you know, I have been writing a book on disclosure dilemmas and how to think through them. So I thought this is a good exercise for me. And one of the ways we go wrong when we consider whether to reveal something, one of the things that we tend to overlook is the risks of concealing. I realize that what's really salient in these decisions is the risks of revealing, right? What I just said, reasons why I would not reveal is I don't want them to think I'm petty. I don't want them to feel bad. Those are all risks of revealing. Sins of commission, risks of revealing. But what we don't think about are what are the risks of holding back. We don't naturally think about those. And so if I forced myself to think about them, I thought,
这些愚蠢的署名。这不重要，顺其自然吧。但是，你知道，我一直在写一本关于袒露困境以及如何思考这些困境的书。所以我想这对我是个很好的练习。当我们考虑是否要袒露某事时，我们犯错的方式之一，我们往往会忽视的一个方面就是隐瞒的风险。我意识到，在这些决定中真正显眼的是袒露的风险，对吧？我刚才说的，我不愿意袒露的原因是我不想让他们觉得我小气。我不想让他们难过。这些全都是袒露的风险。作为的罪过，袒露的风险。但我们没有考虑到的是隐瞒的风险是什么。我们不会自然而然地去想这些。所以如果我强迫自己去想它们，我想，
well, I might ruminate and then just have resentment potentially bubble up over the years. And then I thought, okay, and what about something I also don't usually consider is the benefits of speaking my mind, if I do it in a figure out a nice way to say it. Well, if I say the benefits, if I say why, if I tell them this, one of the benefits might be they will know me better. They will know that I really care about ideas and that's important to me. And then that will make me happy with them knowing that they know me, right? Because feeling known for who you are is just so deeply rewarding. So then I started to see kind of the other side of it, so much so that I actually ended up having a conversation about it and it went just fine. So did they not feel like you were being petty? I mean,
嗯，我可能会反刍，然后多年来怨恨情绪可能会滋生。然后我想，好吧，还有什么是我通常不考虑的，那就是说出心里话的好处，如果我用一种好的方式说出来的话。好吧，如果我说出好处，如果我说为什么，如果我把这个告诉他们，好处之一可能是他们会更了解我。他们会知道我真的很在乎想法，这对我很重要。然后，这会让我因为他们了解我而感到高兴，对吧？因为因真实的自我而被了解，那种感觉实在是太深刻、太有回报了。于是我开始看到事情的另一面，以至于我最后真的和他们谈了谈，而且一切顺利。那么，他们没有觉得你很小气吗？我的意思是，
were your concerns completely unfounded? So they didn't show it, if they may have thought it. But I didn't read that at all. In fact, one of them like teared up, as I was saying, I could tell she felt really badly. And then I, of course, said, like, I love you and it's fine. And it's like, you were doing a great thing. This is why I love collaborating with you because we're not, we're not excessively credit-seeking or petty, you know? Like, that's what makes it wonderful. So it brought us closer.
你的担忧完全是多余的吗？他们没有表现出来，如果他们心里可能是这么想的话。但我一点也没看出来。事实上，其中一个人甚至眼眶湿润了，当我这么说的时候，我能看出她觉得非常糟糕。然后我当然说了，我爱你，没关系。就像，你在做一件很棒的事。这就是为什么我喜欢和你合作，因为我们不是，我们不是那种过分追求署名权或小气的人，你知道吗？就像，这就是它的美妙之处。所以这拉近了我们的距离。
You can see the way I'm even getting kind of worked up in a good way by talking about it. It also, interestingly, when you share these things, it also tells you more about the people you're working with. So this was so affirming of our collaborations together. I've had this conversation, a similar one with another group, where one of the co-authors was just, it went really badly. and she was kind of aggressive and angry. And it wasn't just a natural defensiveness in the moment, but it kind of persisted. And that was also informative, right?
你可以看出，我甚至因为谈论这件事而变得情绪高涨，而且是朝着好的方向。有趣的是，当你分享这些事情时，它也会让你更多地了解和你一起工作的人。所以这非常肯定了我们之间的合作。我曾与另一个团队有过类似的谈话，其中一位合作作者只是，结果非常糟糕。她表现得有点具有攻击性和愤怒。这不仅仅是当时一种自然的防御心理，而且这种情绪一直持续着。这也是很有信息量的，对吧？
Because people's true colors really show when they're in, when they get disappointing information. I want you to tell me another story, Leslie. This one was more consequential. It had to do with a young man you met some years ago when you were single. His name was Colin. How did you meet and how did that relationship unfold?
因为当人们面对令人失望的信息时，他们的本性才会真正显露出来。莱斯利，我想让你给我讲另一个故事。这个故事更具分量。它和你多年前单身时遇到的一位年轻男子有关。他叫科林。你们是怎么认识的？这段关系又是如何发展的？
Yeah. So we met in the most romantic of ways, i.e. Tinder. It's funny because I was in my 30s professing, and it's very ironic that I met him on like the most hookupy app. I was looking for a long-term partner. But the reason I chose Tinder was because it had amazing privacy settings because at the time it was the only app where I could. set it up so a guy would only see me if I had swiped right on him because I just lived in fear of an MBA student seeing me on this, right? I lived in Harvard Square. So I'm like, I can't, I can't have my students seeing me. So that's why I was on Tinder. I always feel the need to justify it a bit. But anyways, I, um, so we found each other on Tinder and we started dating and it was wonderful. Um, and we went on this romantic weekend of Palm Springs. And I, I just,
是的。所以我们以最浪漫的方式相遇，也就是Tinder。说实话，这很搞笑，因为我三十多岁的时候还在当教授，而我竟然在一个最常用来约炮的软件上认识了他，这非常具有讽刺意味。我当时在寻找长期伴侣。但我选择Tinder的原因是它拥有惊人的隐私设置，因为在当时它是唯一一个我可以进行设置的软件，只有当我向右滑了他，他才能看到我，因为我生活在对MBA学生在上面看到我的恐惧中，对吧？我住在哈佛广场。所以我想，我不能，我不能让我的学生看到我。这就是我为什么用Tinder的原因。我总觉得需要为此辩解一番。但无论如何，我，呃，我们在Tinder上找到了彼此，我们开始约会，这太棒了。呃，我们在棕榈泉度过了一个浪漫的周末。而我，我只是，
I was really feeling love vibes. But I was too shy, scared, all of these things to say it. And so we were in our room and I said, I think it was like the trying to bring up the relationship definition conversation. I said, oh, so what are we? I think is what I said. And he's like, oh, I'm having a lot of fun or something like that. that just, it felt like I was shut down. And so that was a very disappointing response
我真的感受到了恋爱的氛围。但我太害羞了，害怕说出口，所有这些原因都有。所以我们在房间里，我说，我想当时就像是试图挑起关于定义关系的谈话。我说，哦，那我们算什么？我想我当时是这么说的。他说，哦，我玩得很开心，或者类似的话。这感觉就像是我被拒绝了。所以那是一个非常令人失望的回答，
slash non-response that I got from him. And so I started to feel like question whether he was emotionally available. But then a little while later, he actually was the first to announce, albeit guardedly, his love for me. He said, I think I love you. And I said, me, you too.
或者说是我从他那里得到的非语言回应。所以我开始怀疑他是否在情感上做好了准备。但过了一会儿，实际上是他第一个宣布了他对我的爱，尽管表现得有所保留。他说，我想我爱妳。我说，我也是。
Me, YouTube. Want, want, want. Because I think I couldn't say the L word, even though I was feeling that. I just had a hard time expressing it. And it was one of these moments I just going to blurt it out. Me, you too. And you can never go back from that. You can't just then be like, oh, yeah, I meant to say I love you.
我也是。啊，啊，啊。因为我想我说不出“爱”这个字，即使我当时确实有这种感觉。我只是很难表达出来。那是那种我只想脱口而出的时刻。我也是。而一旦说出口就再也无法收回了。你不能随后又说，哦，是的，我本意是说我爱你。
And so then more time passed. And, you know, I always felt like, oh, he's emotionally reserved. But in hindsight, I was just as if not more reserved. And he was like, I felt these strong feelings. From day one, our first date, I was, there was something really special and different about him in a good way. But in the days that followed, Leslie and Colin started to feel awkward around each other. Leslie was sure that Colin regretted telling her that he loved her. At the back of her mind, she reminded herself that he had said, I think I love you.
于是更多的时间过去了。而且，你知道，我总是觉得，哦，他在情感上很保守。但事后看来，我和他一样保守，甚至有过之而无不及。而他说：我感受到了这种强烈的情感。从第一天起，我们的第一次约会，我就觉得，他身上有些非常特别、与众不同的地方，是好的那种。但在接下来的日子里，莱斯利和科林开始觉得彼此有些尴尬。莱斯利确信科林后悔对她表白了。在心底深处，她提醒自己他说的是“我想我爱你”。
He only thought he loved her. That wasn't love, was it? Slowly, the conversations between them got more and more stilted. Leslie felt she was in relationship limbo. One day, Leslie asked to have a chat and told Colin she thought they should break up. He didn't argue with her or plead with her to change her mind. He said he would get his stuff and leave. Leslie was hurt Colin hadn't fought for the relationship,
他只是“觉得”他爱她。那可不是爱，对吧？渐渐地，他们之间的对话变得越来越生硬。莱斯利觉得自己处于关系的灰色地带。有一天，莱斯利要求谈一谈，并告诉科林她觉得他们应该分手。他没有和她争辩，也没有恳求她改变主意。他说他会去收拾东西离开。莱斯利很难过科林没有为这段感情争取一下，
but she told herself, see, it shows he doesn't love me. And I was really sad about it. and I really, I felt like I had lost out. And then I had a tremendous stroke of luck because one day there was a card that showed up on my doorstep, a handwritten note. It didn't even have a stamp on it. And it was in his handwriting, which I knew. So I got home and it's just mega swoon. There's this handwritten card. He was there. He had dropped it off. So I opened it up. And it's this amazing love letter. and it was so honest. I actually have it here.
但她告诉自己：看吧，这表明他不爱我。我对此感到非常难过，我真的觉得我失去了很多。然后我运势大好，因为有一天门廊上出现了一张卡片，一张手写的便签。上面甚至连邮票都没有。那是他的笔迹，我认得出来。所以我回到家，简直心动到爆。有一张手写的卡片。他来过。他把它放在那里的。所以我把它打开了。这是一封神奇的情书，它是如此诚实。我其实把它带在身边了。
I wanted to read a part of it. Okay, he said, If I'm being honest with myself, I know that I do love you. I know I was scared of admitting that I was in love with you, scared to embrace how I was feeling about you, and scared to let myself be in love with you,
我想读其中的一部分。好吧，他说，如果我对自我坦诚，我知道我是爱你的。我知道我害怕承认我爱上了你，害怕接受我对你的感受，害怕让自己去爱上你，
and all that meant. Oh, and so then I texted him, and of course I couldn't pick up the phone call, and call him like a grown-up, I texted him and I said, you know, hi, I got your lovely letter. And I'm literally staring at my screen and I see the bubbles pop up. He's, we're communicating. He's texting. So then we met up again and we started seeing each other again. And a whirlwind romance ensued.
以及这意味着的一切。哦，所以然后我给他发了短信，我当然没有拿起电话像个成年人一样打给他，我发短信说，你知道，嗨，我收到了你可爱的信。我简直目不转睛地盯着屏幕，看到气泡弹出来。他在，我们在交流。他在发短信。然后我们又见面了，我们又开始约会了。随之而来的是一段旋风般的浪漫恋情。
And then a year later, we were married. And then two wonderful little children followed. I'm so grateful that he had the courage to do that because I would have never had the life that I have now. I wouldn't have the children. I wouldn't have, yeah, my prince charming. Over the last two weeks, we've looked at the many reasons to reveal ourselves to others. But that doesn't mean we should always blurt out everything on our minds. There are, in fact, times when it might be best to withhold information.
然后一年后，我们结婚了。接着两个可爱的小天使出生了。我非常感激他有那样的勇气，因为我绝不会拥有现在这样的生活。我不会有这些孩子，我不会有，是的，我的白马王子。在过去的两周里，我们探讨了向他人袒露自我的诸多原因。但这并不意味着我们应该总是把脑子里的所有想法脱口而出。事实上，有时最好还是把信息保留在心里。
That's in our Hidden Brain Plus episode titled, When to Hide the Truth. If you're a subscriber, that episode should be available in your podcast feed right now. If you're not yet a subscriber, please go to support.hiddenbrain.org. If you're using an Apple device, go to apple.com slash hiddenbrain. Again, that's support.hiddenbrain.org and apple.com slash hidden brain. Psychologist Leslie John is the author of Revealing, the underrated power of oversharing. Leslie, thank you so much for joining me today on Hidden Brain. You're welcome. Thank you for having me.
这就在我们的《隐藏的大脑·Plus》节目中，标题是《何时隐瞒真相》。如果你是订阅者，该节目现在应该已经可以在你的播客动态中收听了。如果你还不是订阅者，请访问support.hiddenbrain.org。如果你使用的是苹果设备，请访问apple.com/hiddenbrain。再次提醒，网址是support.hiddenbrain.org和apple.com/hiddenbrain。心理学家莱斯利·约翰是《袒露：过度分享的被低估的力量》一书的作者。莱斯利，非常感谢你今天来到《隐藏的大脑》。不客气。谢谢你邀请我。
Can you think of a time when you came clean to someone else? Do you remember what happened and how it felt? If you're willing to share your personal story with the Hidden Brain audience or have a question or comment about self-concealment and self-disclosure, please find a very quiet room and record a voice memo on your phone. Two or three minutes is plenty. Email the file to us at Feedback. at hiddenbrain.org.
你能想起什么时候曾向别人坦白过吗？你还记得发生了什么以及当时的感觉吗？如果你愿意与《隐藏的大脑》听众分享你的个人故事，或者对隐瞒自我和自我袒露有任何疑问或评论，请找一个非常安静的房间，在手机上录制一段语音备忘录。两三分钟就足够了。请将文件发送至我们的邮箱：Feedback@hiddenbrain.org。
Use the subject line, secrets. Again, that's feedback at hiddenbrain.org. One of the most significant contexts in which we often think about topics like secrets and self-disclosure is in our romantic relationships. We want our partners to be the person with whom we share everything,
请使用主题词：秘密。再次提醒，邮箱是feedback@hiddenbrain.org。我们经常会思考秘密和自我袒露等话题的最重要语境之一，就是我们的浪漫关系。我们希望伴侣成为那个与我们分享一切的人，
but we also want to keep a bit of excitement and mystery in our relationships. We've talked about this on the show with psychologist Eli Feelea Finkel, who has studied what he calls the all-or-nothing marriage. After the break, Eli returns to the show to answer your questions about the pressures we put on our romantic relationships and how we might want to take some of the pressure off ourselves and our partners. You won't want to miss it.
但我们也希望在关系中保留一点刺激感和神秘感。我们在节目中与心理学家埃利·菲利·芬克尔探讨过这一点，他一直在研究他所谓的“全有或全无的婚姻”。休息过后，埃利将重返节目，回答你关于我们对浪漫关系施加的压力以及我们可能希望如何减轻自己和伴侣身上的一些压力的提问。你一定不想错过。
You're listening to Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedanta. This is Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedanta. Think back to the last time you realized you were falling in love. How would you describe that feeling? Was it thrilling? Maybe a little scary? Perhaps you remember it as a phase when you and your love would talk for hours, chatting about nothing and everything.
您正在收听的是《隐藏的大脑》。我是香卡·维丹塔姆。这里是《隐藏的大脑》。我是香卡·维丹塔姆。回想一下你最后一次意识到自己坠入爱河的时候。你会如何形容那种感觉？是惊心动魄吗？也许还有点害怕？也许你还记得那是你和爱人交谈几个小时的阶段，什么都聊，无所不谈。
This honeymoon phase of a romantic relationship can be euphoric. As the relationship deepens, new things are added to the heady buzz of love. You come to rely on your partner. If you stay together, your lover becomes your confidant, your cheerleader, your support system. Over time, the demands we have for our soulmates only increase. We want the passionate lover and we want the stable partner. We want the amazing parent and the adventurer, the impulsive travel companion and the rock who stands by us in tough times.
浪漫关系的蜜月期可能会让人欣喜若狂。随着关系的加深，新的内容被加入到爱情令人陶醉的兴奋中。你开始依赖伴侣。如果你能长相厮守，你的爱人就会成为你的知己、你的啦啦队长、你的支持系统。随着时间的推移，我们对灵魂伴侣的要求只会越来越多。我们既想要充满激情的爱人，又想要稳定的伴侣。我们想要出色的父母和冒险家，想要冲动的旅行同伴以及在艰难时刻坚定支持我们的坚强后盾。
We want funny, we want brave, we want kind, and of course, we still want the gorgeous person we fell in love with to stay gorgeous. At Northwestern University, psychologist Eli Finkel examines what happens when we ask one person to play so many roles for us. He's the author of the All or Nothing marriage, how the best marriages work. We first talked with Eli back in 2018, and our conversation has remained enduringly popular. You can find a link to it in the show notes. Today, Eli returns to Hidden Brain for your questions answered, our segment where guests come back to the show to answer questions from listeners. Eli Finkel, welcome back to Hidden Brain.
我们希望对方有趣、勇敢、善良，当然，我们仍然希望让我们坠入爱河的那个绝美的人能够一直保持美丽。在西北大学，心理学家埃利·芬克尔研究了当我们要求一个人为我们扮演如此多的角色时会发生什么。他是《全或零婚姻：最好的婚姻是如何运作的》一书的作者。我们最早在2018年采访过埃利，我们的对话一直非常受欢迎。你可以在节目简介中找到指向它的链接。今天，埃利重返《隐藏的大脑》参与“解答你的问题”，这是我们的标志性环节，嘉宾会重返节目回答听众的提问。埃利·芬克尔，欢迎回到《隐藏的大脑》。
for having me. I'm excited to be back. Eli, in our first conversation, we discussed what you call the all-or-nothing marriage. What do you mean by that term? It's a way of capturing the current era of marriage. And what I did when I was exploring these ideas is I tracked the historical trajectory of what is it that we expect from our marriage. And once I delved into the sociology and the history, I realize that our expectations today are different in some pretty radical ways from how they used to be in the past. I mean, we can go back a couple hundred years and think about what would we be looking for from our marriage if we were not in 2025, but like 1825. And what we looked for in a spouse was the fulfillment of really basic needs. I literally mean
谢谢邀请。很高兴能回来。埃利，在我们第一次对话中，我们讨论了你所说的“全有或全无的婚姻”。你这个术语是什么意思？这是捕捉当前婚姻时代的一种方式。当我探索这些想法时，我追踪了我们对婚姻的期望的历史轨迹。一旦我深入研究了社会学和历史，我意识到我们今天的期望与过去相比发生了相当激进的变化。我的意思是，我们可以追溯到几百年前，想想如果我们不是生活在2025年，而是生活在1825年，我们会从婚姻中寻找什么。当时我们在配偶身上寻找的是最基本需求的满足。我字面上的意思是，
things like food, clothing, shelter. It's true that people preferred to love their spouse, and if the sex were good, that would be terrific. But that wasn't the point of marriage. People didn't get up on the marriage altar and say, I'm marrying you because you complete me. So today we expect our partners to be everything for us, a lover, a best friend, a therapist. We want them to represent a safe place, but also an exciting one. How did our expectations of marriage change so radically, Eli? Yeah, you're exactly right. So from this, you know, basic shared farmhouse way of thinking up until today when we witness our loved ones stand on the marriage altar and say things like you complete me, you're my best friend, the two major things that shifted
诸如食物、衣服、住所之类的事情。确实，人们更愿意爱自己的配偶，如果性生活很美满，那就太棒了。但这并不是婚姻的意义所在。人们不会走上婚礼圣坛说：我娶你/嫁给你是因为你完整了我。所以今天我们期望伴侣成为我们的一切：爱人、最好的朋友、治疗师。我们希望他们代表一个安全的地方，同时也希望是一个激动人心的地方。埃利，我们对婚姻的期望是如何发生如此激进的变化的？是的，你说得完全正确。因此，从这种（你知道的）传统的共享农舍式的思维方式，直到今天我们见证我们所爱的人站在婚礼圣坛上说出诸如“你完整了我”、“你是我最好的朋友”这样的话，在过去的几百年里，发生变化的两个主要方面是：
over the last couple hundred years, the first were changes to the economy. And in contrast to the agricultural era, we saw this urbanization. It really picked up after the 1850s. And what you get with urbanization is a surfeit of jobs in urban centers. And so for the first time ever anywhere, young people move to cities and they are geographically and economically independent of their parents. And what is it that they want? They want to feel personally fulfilled. And so, yes, it used to be nice for a marriage to be fulfilling, but since that time, the personal fulfillment of the spouses becomes essential. And that change to the economy. dovetails with changes in our culture.
首先是经济的变化。与农业时代相比，我们看到了这种城市化进程。它在1850年代之后真正加速了。城市化带来的结果是城市中心的工作岗位过剩。因此，世界上的年轻人第一次搬到城市，他们在地理和经济上都独立于父母。他们想要什么？他们想要感到个人的自我实现。所以，是的，过去婚姻能带来成就感是件好事，但从那时起，配偶个人的自我实现变得至关重要。经济上的这种变化，
We've seen a lot of changes to our culture, but perhaps the most relevant one here is the rise in the 20th century of humanistic psychology. These are people like Abraham Maslow who talks about things like self-actualization. And so on the one hand, we've got the changes to the economy
与我们文化的变化相吻合。我们的文化经历了许多变化，但这里最相关的也许是20世纪人本主义心理学的兴起。这些人物包括亚伯拉罕·马斯洛，他谈到了诸如自我实现之类的事情。因此，一方面，我们看到了经济的变化，
such that people are now independent, making decisions for themselves and their personal fulfillment, and they are emphasizing not only love, but also the idea that our spouse should help us live an authentic self-actualizing life. You mentioned the psychologist Abraham Maslow. Remind us about his famous hierarchy of needs
以至于人们现在独立了，为自己和个人的自我实现做决定，他们不仅强调爱，还强调这样一种观点：我们的配偶应该帮助我们过上真实且自我实现的生活。你提到了心理学家亚伯拉罕·马斯洛。请提醒我们他著名的需求层次理论，
and the corollary that you saw between this model and our approach to marriage today. Yeah, this is one of the most famous ideas in the history of psychology. The idea is that our needs are not just a random smattering of things that we would like, but that they exist in a hierarchy and some of the more fundamental needs are things like physiological and safety needs,
以及你在这一模型与我们今天的婚姻方法之间看到的对应关系。是的，这是心理学史上最著名的观点之一。这个观点是，我们的需求不仅仅是我们所希望的各种随机事物的拼凑，而是它们存在于一个层次结构中，其中一些更基础的需求是诸如生理和安全需求之类的东西，
literally things like the need to stay warm, the need to have enough food. And then you go up his hierarchy if those needs are at least somewhat met and you look to other sorts of needs. And to the middle of his hierarchy, you see things like love and belonging. And then as you look toward the top of this hierarchy, you get more psychologically oriented needs like esteem and self-actualization needs. And your argument is that in some ways the story of marriage, in some ways has marched up this hierarchy of needs. It used to be that we looked to marriage to fulfill more of our basic needs, but now we increasingly look to marriage to fulfill our very highest needs.
字面上的意思，比如保持温暖的需求，有足够食物的需求。如果这些需求至少在一定程度上得到满足，你就会顺着他的层次结构往上走，去寻找其他种类的需求。在他人字塔的中间，你会看到爱和归属感之类的东西。然后，当你向这个层次结构的顶部看时，你会得到更多以心理为导向的需求，比如尊重和自我实现的需求。你的观点是，在某种程度上，婚姻的故事一直在顺着这个需求层次向上攀登。过去，我们指望婚姻来满足我们更多基本的需求，但现在，我们越来越指望婚姻来满足我们最高端的需求。
Yes, that is exactly what we've seen over time. And it is interesting because I'm certainly among the people who have observed that we're asking more and more of our spouse over time, how can we achieve those things in our marriage? the level of understanding, the level of communication that we need to have for each other. If we're going to help each other, I don't know, conquer our unconscious blocks and our fear of success in order to break through to the other side to achieve the most authentic ideal version of ourselves, it's really hard. But there's a second thing that happens, and I think we really need to appreciate this one. It's at the top of Maslow's hierarchy that we get deep, profound feelings.
是的，这正是我们随着时间推移所看到的。这很有趣，因为我当然是那些观察到随着时间的推移，我们对配偶的要求越来越多的观察者之一，我们如何在婚姻中实现这些东西呢？我们需要为彼此达到的理解水平、沟通水平。如果我们打算互相帮助，我不知道，克服我们的无意识障碍和对成功的恐惧，以便突破重围，实现我们最真实的、理想的自我版本，这真的很难。但还有第二件事发生了，我认为我们真的需要认识到这一点。正是在马斯洛金字塔的顶端，我们获得了深刻的、深远的情感，
of fulfillment. At the bottom, sure, of course we need to have enough food. Of course it's terrible to be freezing. But as Maslow himself said, it's the higher need gratifications that produce more profound happiness, serenity, and richness of the inner life. So we've shifted in a way that makes connecting more difficult and many of us are disappointed with a level of marital connection that would have been totally okay for our grandparents. But those of us who are looking to the top and succeeding, are achieving a level of marital connection that was out of reach in earlier eras. So in some ways, Eli, what you're saying is that the much higher expectations that we have of marriage produce something of a paradox. For the couples who manage
即成就感。在底层，当然，我们需要有足够的食物。当然，挨冻是糟糕的。但正如马斯洛本人所说，是更高层次的需求满足产生了更深刻的幸福感、宁静感和内心世界的丰富性。因此，我们的转变使得建立联系变得更加困难，我们中的许多人对那种对于我们的祖父母来说完全没问题的婚姻连接水平感到失望。但我们这些仰望顶峰并取得成功的人，正在实现早期时代遥不可及的婚姻连接水平。所以从某种程度上说，埃利，你是在说，我们对婚姻高得多的期望产生了一种悖论。对于那些设法满足这些期望的夫妇来说，
to meet those expectations, they end up incredibly happy and potentially much happier than couples were 200 years ago. But for many people who are not able to ascend to the very people, of Mount Maslow, as you call it, people find that their relationships are falling short. That is exactly right. And that's the idea behind the all or nothing marriage. We've created an era that affords the possibility of a level of connection that was difficult to achieve when people weren't looking to the top of Maslow's hierarchy, while at the same time placed a lot of people at risk for disappointment because those expectations are oriented toward the top. And I should just say one of the things that I think this theory can explain that no other theory can really account for is the extent to which having a happy marriage is linked to being overall happy in our lives is twice as strong today as it was a few decades ago.
他们最终会感到无比幸福，潜力上比200年时的夫妇要幸福得多。但对于许多无法登上马斯洛之山（正如你所称的）顶峰的人来说，人们发现他们的关系正在走下坡路。完全正确。这就是全或无婚姻背后的理念。我们创造了一个时代，它提供了达到某种连接水平的可能性，而在人们不把目光投向马斯洛金字塔顶端时，这种连接水平是很难实现的，与此同时，这也让许多人面临失望的风险，因为这些期望是以顶端为导向的。我只想说，我认为这个理论能解释而其他任何理论都无法真正解释的一点是，拥有美满的婚姻与对整体生活感到幸福之间的联系，今天比几十年前要强烈两倍。
And I think the reason why is because there's so much more variability in terms of how fulfilled we feel in our marriage. The top end is exceptional. The average is maybe getting worse. And so sticking the landing on having a happy, fulfilling marriage is more important today than it was in the past. So some listeners wrote in about the role of expectations in marriage and the challenge that high expectations can pose. Diana wrote, like Dr. Finkel, I agree that unmet expectations cause negative feelings. However, I strongly disagree with his opinion of the need to lower expectations. Lowering implies a decrease in quality or a lesser rate.
我想原因在于，我们在婚姻中感受到满足的程度有更多的变异性。顶端是卓越的，平均水平可能在变糟。因此，在拥有一个幸福、美满的婚姻上稳操胜券，在今天比过去更加重要。因此，一些听众写信讨论了期望在婚姻中的作用以及高希冀可能带来的挑战。黛安娜写道：像芬克尔博士一样，我同意未满足的期望会导致消极情绪。然而，我强烈不同意他关于需要降低期望的观点。降低暗示着质量的下降或较差的，
experience, I would suggest that you need to change or adapt your expectations to support the reality of what's happening in your lives and the relationship. Discussing expectations openly with your partner and mutually agreeing on what can be expected will go a long way in creating a loving, happy relationship. What do you think, Eli? Are you recommending that people lower their expectations, or like Diana, are you saying that people in some way should discuss her expectations and come to a mutually satisfactory conclusion? conclusion. Yeah, I see eye to eye with Diana on this. I think there are two things I'd like to say in response to her. The first one is that she's right about the importance of communicating about what
体验，我建议你需要改变或调整你的期望，以支持你生活和关系中正在发生的事情的现实。与你的伴侣公开讨论期望，并就预期达成共识，对于建立充满爱意的幸福关系大有裨益。你怎么看，埃利？你是建议人们降低期望，还是像黛安娜一样，认为人们在某种程度上应该讨论她的期望并达成双方满意的结论？结论。是的，我在这方面与黛安娜看法一致。我有两点想对她的评论作出回应。首先，她关于沟通我们将会和不会抱有什么期望的重要性的看法是正确的。而且让我说，我认为人们在表达他们期望婚姻提供什么方面做得更多，而对于他们愿意说“婚姻不必提供这些”则做得远远不够。我认为通过与伴侣的沟通以及对自己诚实的评估，我们可以决定哪些是我们必须通过这段单一关系来满足的事情，而哪些是完全可以通过其他关系或靠自己来满足的。第二点我想说的是，期望起到了两种不同的作用。一是它们设定了一个标准，我们将根据这个标准来评估我们正在经历的体验。在这里，高期望实际上是不利的，因为鉴于你可能拥有的任何一系列体验，如果你期望较低，你会比期望较高时对它们更满意。但黛安娜绝对是正确的。期望还有第二种作用，那就是它们充当了一种动力。正因为我对婚姻抱有很高的期望，所以我投入了很多。我朝着这些目标努力。我尝试以正朝着马斯洛金字塔顶端导向的那些方式去连接。正是这些动机、这些高期望，才提供了如此深厚的婚姻连接的可能性。可以肯定地说，婚姻的结束很少是愉快的，但当你的很大一部分身份都围绕着这段关系构建时，当它破裂时，就会格外痛苦。我想为你播放一位名叫索尔的听众的经历。
we will and won't expect. And let me say, I think people do a whole lot more of articulating what they expect the marriage to deliver than what they're willing to say, the marriage doesn't have to deliver these things. And I think through communication with our partner and through honest assessment with ourselves, we can decide which are the things we have to meet through this one relationship versus which are the things that are totally acceptable to meet either through other relationships or on our own. The second thing I'd like to say is that expectations do two different things. One is they set a standard according to which we're going to evaluate the experiences we're having. And here, high expectations are in fact disadvantageous because given any set of experiences
我们会期望什么，不会期望什么。我想说的是，人们更多地是在表达他们期望婚姻带来什么，而不是他们愿意说明婚姻不必带来这些东西。我认为通过与伴侣的沟通以及对自己的诚实评估，我们可以决定哪些是必须通过这段单一关系满足的需求，哪些是通过其他关系或靠自己满足也完全可以接受的需求。我要说的第二点是，期望会起到两方面的作用。一方面，它们设定了一个标准，我们将根据这个标准来评估我们正在经历的体验。在这里，高希冀实际上是不利的，因为无论你有怎样的体验
you might have, you'll be more pleased with them if you expected less than if you expected more. But Diana is absolutely right. There is a second thing that expectations do, which is that they serve as a motivational force. And so because I expect a lot from the marriage, I invest a lot. I push toward those things. I try to connect in exactly those ways that are oriented toward the top of Maslow's hierarchy. And it's those motivations, those high expectations that afford the possibility of such a deep marital connection. I think it's safe to say that the end of a marriage is rarely fun, but when a large part of your identity is built around that relationship, it can be especially painful when it doesn't work out. I'd like to play for you the experience
如果你期望较低，你会比期望较高时对它们更满意。但戴安娜完全是对的。期望还有第二种作用，那就是它们充当了一种激励力量。正因为我对婚姻抱有很高的期望，所以我投入了很多。我朝着这些目标努力。我试图以那些完全面向马斯洛需求层次顶端的方式去连接。正是这些动力、这些高期望，才带来了如此深厚婚姻连接的可能性。我认为可以肯定地说，一段婚姻的结束很少是愉快的，但当你的很大一部分身份都是围绕着这段关系构建的时，当它破裂时，会显得格外痛苦。我想给你们播放一段经历
of a listener named Soul. My wife and I were together for a total of 24 years, married for 22 of them, and I could not have been happier for most of the time. I have a tattoo of her in my arm, I wrote a book about our honeymoon. I just like made my whole identity be how much I was devoted to her. Through no fault of her own, she realized that she's gay. And that obviously came as a bombshell, I think, to both of us. And it obviously meant a lot of changes. We have four children.
我和我太太一共在一起24年，结婚22年，在大部分时间里我都感到无比幸福。我的手臂上有她的纹身，我还写了一本关于我们蜜月的书。我只是把我的整个身份都变成了我对她有多么忠诚。在并非她过错的情况下，她意识到自己是个同性恋。这显然对我们俩来说都像是一个重磅炸弹。这显然意味着许多改变。我们有四个孩子，
and we told them this. And I did not see us breaking up as possible. And I couldn't be more disappointed because our story was everything to me. It was so beautiful. It was so wonderful. I thought we were just destined to be. So Eli, I feel for soul,
我们把这件事告诉了他们。我从未想过我们会分手，这是不可能的。我感到无比失望，因为我们的故事对我来说就是一切。它是那么美丽。它是那么美妙。我以为我们注定要在一起。所以，埃利，我为索尔感到难过，
he says his whole identity was wrapped up in this relationship with his ex-wife. And it appears he was. someone who thought he had reached the heights of Mount Maslow only to find himself losing the relationship. I'm wondering what you would say to Seoul as he begins charting a new identity for himself. I sympathize with him enormously. I'm sort of tearing up a little as I'm listening to his story. It is a beautiful, poignant, sad, touching story. And it is very much a story of the current era. He understands and his wife understands that if she's gay, she shouldn't be expected to remain in a
他说他的整个身份都包裹在这段与前妻的关系中。而且看起来他确实是这样。一个自以为已经达到了马斯洛之山高度的人，却发现自己失去了这段关系。我在想，当索尔开始为自己规划一份新的身份时，你会对他说些什么。我非常同情他。当我听到他的故事时，我甚至有点想哭。这是一个美丽、凄美、悲伤、感人的故事。这非常符合当前时代的故事。他和他的妻子都明白，如果她是同性恋，就不应该指望她继续留在
marriage to a man. That would be inconsistent with who she is. And I think he's capturing one of the great risks of the all or nothing era. He, so far as we can tell, really did build one of these top of Maslow's hierarchy, deep, profound level of connection and all the psychological sorts of ways. And when that ends, we really are left unmoored, sometimes even bereft. He didn't comment specifically about this. But one of the risky things about the current era of marriage is we don't attend as much as we used to to what I've called the other significant others, our family members, our close friends, our cousins, right? We don't attend as much as we used to and continue to invest in those relationships. And that means that if this all marriage that we've been pursuing,
一段与男人的婚姻中。那将与她是谁相矛盾。我认为他抓住了“全或无”时代的最大风险之一。据我们所知，他确实建立了一个达到马斯洛金字塔顶端的、深厚的、各方面心理都极度契合的连接水平。而当这一切结束时，我们真的变得无所依托，有时甚至被剥夺了一切。他没有具体评论这一点。但当前婚姻时代的风险之一是，我们不像过去那样关注我所谓的“其他重要他人”——我们的家庭成员、我们的密友、我们的表亲，对吧？我们不像过去那样关注并继续投资于这些关系。这意味着，如果我们一直在追求的所有婚姻，
the one atop Maslow's hierarchy, if it falters, we're left without the same level of social backdrop that we might have had otherwise. I'm wondering also, Eli, if it's possible that in some ways our high expectations of marriage have meant that fewer people are now able to fit the bill. In other words, if I expect my partner to be my soulmate, my friend, my financial comrade, my everything, perhaps there are fewer and fewer suitors whom I might consider appropriate. I think that's a fair observation that insofar as our list of required attributes, especially for these sorts of social and psychological sorts of needs that we have, insofar as that list gets longer and deeper, the proportion of people, the number of people
那个处于马斯洛金字塔顶端的婚姻，如果它动摇了，我们将失去原本可能拥有的那种社会后盾。埃利，我也在想，在某种程度上，我们对婚姻的高期望是否意味着现在能够符合标准的人更少了？换句话说，如果我期望我的伴侣成为我的灵魂伴侣、朋友、财务战友、我的一切，也许我可能认为合适的追求者就会越来越少。我认为这是一个公平的观察，鉴于我们所需属性的清单，特别是对于这些社会和心理方面的需求而言，随着这个清单变得越来越长、越来越深刻，人们的比例、那些能够为我们满足这些需求的人数，
who might be able to fulfill that for us gets smaller. And it feels like we would be settling in a way that would be a violation to an authentic life to be with somebody who couldn't fulfill those needs. When we come back, a closer look at some of the stressors that impact relationships and what we can do about them. You're listening to Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. This is Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. At Northwestern University, psychologist Eli Finkel studies the science of relationships.
变得越来越少。感觉我们会采取一种妥协，而这对于一个真实的生活来说将是一种违背，去和一个无法满足这些需求的人在一起。稍后回来，我们将近距离审视一些影响关系的压力源以及我们可以采取的应对措施。您正在收听的是《隐藏的大脑》。我是香卡·维丹塔姆。这里是《隐藏的大脑》。我是香卡·维丹塔姆。在西北大学，心理学家埃利·芬克尔研究关系的科学。
He looks at why couples might be more likely to stay together and also why they might fall apart. Eli, let's talk about some of the stressors that can affect marriages. One of the most common stressors is money. Partners often differ on how to get money and whether to save, spend, or invested. You published a study that looked at the psychology of how financial struggles in relationships can affect the outcome. of those relationships. Tell me what you found. There are two major findings linking things like income to relationship well-being. The first one construes low income as a source of stress. And what we see in that literature is that you just fight more. There's more things to fight about
他探讨了为什么伴侣更有可能在一起，以及为什么他们可能会分道扬镳。埃利，我们来谈谈一些可能影响婚姻的压力源。最常见的压力源之一就是金钱。伴侣经常在如何赚钱以及是储蓄、消费还是投资上存在分歧。你曾发表过一项研究，考察了关系中的财务挣扎如何影响这些关系的结局的心理学。请讲讲你的发现。有两项主要发现在将收入等因素与关系幸福感联系起来。第一种将低收入解释为一种压力源。我们在相关文献中看到的是，你们吵得更多了。有更多的事情可吵了。
if you don't have enough resources rather than if you do. Right. So for me, in my relationship, we have enough money to make it to the end of the month and pay the rent. We have enough money that if we want to eat out, we can eat out. What happens at the end of the month for people who are really struggling financially? They end up fighting about whose priorities get met, what sacrifices we're willing to make. And even as they're dealing with those additional stressors, there's a second problem, which is they don't have the resources. And here I'm talking financial and also emotional to handle those difficult stressors
资源不足的情况往往比资源充足的情况更能说明问题。没错。对我来说，在我的关系中，我们有足够的钱撑到月底并支付房租。如果我们想出去吃，我们有足够的钱出去吃。对于那些真正陷入财务困境的人来说，月底会发生什么？他们最终会为了谁的优先事项得到满足、我们愿意做出什么牺牲而争吵。即使他们在应对这些额外的压力源时，还有一个第二个问题，那就是他们没有资源。这里我指的是财务资源，还有应对这些困难压力源的情感资源
as effectively, I can go out with my wife to a date and talk about these sorts of issues. We can hire a babysitter to look after the children, to give us time to invest in the relationship and work through those things. And so people who don't have the same level of resources are dealing with this double whammy, where on the one hand, they're handling much more difficult circumstances than the rest of us. And on the other hand, the resources they have available to handle those circumstances are also more limited. Yeah.
同样有效。我可以和我的妻子去约会，谈论这些事情。我们可以请一个保姆来照顾孩子，给我们时间来投资于我们的关系并解决这些问题。因此，那些没有同等水平资源的人正在应对这种双重打击，一方面，他们要应对比我们其他人困难得多的情况；另一方面，他们用来应对这些情况的可用资源也更加有限。是的。
So I'm wondering if this picture that you're painting is part of the reason why research has found that lower income couples are less likely to marry in the first place, and once they do, they're more likely to divorce. Yes, they are less likely to marry, they're more likely to divorce, and the sort of low-hanging explanation for those differences turned out to be wrong. So the initial idea that many scholars had, also cultural commentators often have, is that people who don't have a college degree, maybe don't have a high school degree, don't make that much money, don't really value the institution of marriage enough. But look, we can ask, right? And now there is a bunch of really good research. People who don't have as much money value marriage just as much as people who have more money or more education. One of the things is this stress thing that we've talked about already, but there is a second issue, which is what is it like to be an individual in a more precarious social situation more generally? And the issue here is that there is a more porous safety net, which makes people more dependent on others, but also at greater risk of being exploited or hurt. Not because poorer people are more exploitative or more hurtful, but because on average they are needy. And so many people who have not gotten a college or a high school degree have learned that when push comes to shove, they need to look out for themselves more so than people who are in more comfortable social and economic circumstances have learned to do.
所以我很好奇，你描绘的这幅图景是否是研究发现低收入情侣最初不太可能结婚，而一旦结婚就更可能离婚的部分原因？是的，他们结婚的可能性较小，离婚的可能性更大，而对这些差异的那些容易得出的解释结果却证明是错误的。许多学者甚至文化评论员最初的想法是，那些没有大学文凭、可能没有高中文凭、赚不到那么多钱的人，对婚姻制度本身并没有给予足够的重视。但看吧，我们可以去询问，对吧？现在有很多非常好的研究。没有那么多钱的人和有更多钱或更高教育水平的人一样重视婚姻。其中一件事就是我们已经讨论过的压力问题，但还有第二个问题，那就是作为一个处于更不稳定社会状况中的个别存在，究竟是什么样的？这里的问题在于，安全网更加薄弱，这使得人们更加依赖他人，但也面临着更大的被剥削或伤害的风险。这并不是因为穷人更具剥削性或伤害性，而是因为平均而言他们有需求。因此，许多没有获得大学或高中文凭的人已经了解到，当事情紧迫时，他们需要比处于更舒适社会和经济环境中的人更多地依靠自己。
You also published a study that looked at whether couples who merge their finances or kept them separate, how this decision shaped their relationship. Tell me what you found. This was a cool study. This is a study led by Jenny Olson. We recruited hundreds of couples who were about to get married. All of them were engaged. They were on average about six weeks before their wedding day. And we randomly assigned them to one of three conditions in terms of their bank account
你还发表了一项研究，探讨了合并财务还是保持财务独立的伴侣如何塑造他们的关系。告诉我你发现了什么。这是一项很棒的研究。这是一项由珍妮·奥尔森领导的研究。我们招募了数百对即将结婚的情侣。他们都订婚了。平均在婚礼前大约六周。我们随机将他们分配到银行账户的三种条件之一
structure. So if we imagine these are all heterosexual couples, he has his finances, she has hers, but they haven't yet merged any of their finances. So at the beginning of this study, all of them had entirely. separate bank accounts. And in one of the conditions, we randomly assign them to keep that structure throughout the course of the study, which was a two-year study. In a second condition, we randomly assign them to merge their bank accounts entirely. And then we also have a no intervention control condition. And what we see, if you look at the separate accounts condition or the control condition,
结构。因此，如果我们想象这些都是异性情侣，他有他的财务，她有她的，但他们还没有合并任何财务。因此，在本研究开始时，他们所有人都完全拥有独立的银行账户。在其中一个条件中，我们随机分配他们在为期两年的研究过程中保持这种结构。在第二个条件中，我们随机分配他们完全合并银行账户。然后我们还有一个无干预的对照条件。如果我们看看独立账户条件或对照条件，我们就会看到
you see the standard effect, which is that relationship quality goes down over time. People end up a little bit less satisfied over time over the first two years of their marriage than they were at the beginning. This, I regret to tell you and your listeners, is a standard effect in the research literature that on average relationship quality goes down over time. But in this study, what we found is that those couples who were randomly assigned to merge their finances were buffered against this downward trajectory in relationship quality. They remained approximately as happy over time over the first two years of their marriage, which is all that we studied thus far, they remained about as happy as they were when they were slated to get married.
你会看到标准效应，即关系质量随时间下降。在他们结婚的前两年里，人们最终对关系的满意度比刚开始时略有下降。我遗憾地告诉我和你的听众，这是研究文献中的一个标准效应，即平均而言，关系质量会随着时间的推移而下降。但在本研究中，我们发现那些被随机分配合并财务的情侣得到了缓冲，免受了关系质量下降趋势的影响。在他们结婚的前两年里（这是我们迄今为止研究的全部内容），他们保持了大致相同的幸福感，和他们准备结婚时一样幸福。
And why do you think this is happening? We have several possibilities. We ran a follow-up study. One of the most promising options is the idea that people perceive their relationship as more communal when they've merged their finances than when they've kept their finances separate, for example. And what does it mean to have a communal relationship. It means that it's not your resources and my resources or your time and my time. It's our resources. It's our time. When I'm spending money, I'm spending our money. And I think that headspace tends to merge people a little bit more closely than they would be otherwise. In addition to financial stressors, the people who surround a couple can also
你认为这是为什么呢？我们有几种可能性。我们做了一项后续研究。最有前景的观点之一是，与保持财务独立相比，当人们合并了财务时，他们会认为自己的关系更加具共享性（共同体性质）。拥有共同体关系意味着什么？这意味着这不是你的资源和我的资源，也不是你的时间和我的时间。这是我们的资源。这是我们的时间。当我花钱时，我是在花我们的钱。我认为这种心态往往能让人们比平时更紧密地融合在一起。除了财务压力之外，围绕在伴侣周围的人也可以
put a lot of pressure on a marriage. A listener named Sonia wrote to say, if extended families are not in approval from the beginning, no matter how compatible you are with your partner, this will impact the future of the relationship. Is Sonia correct, Eli? Yes, she is. And I find this one fun because, you know, not many people even know there is a field called relationship science, right? That's sort of my home discipline where we actually collect data to try to answer questions about relationships. And this is one of these times where you just really get a sense of the scientific process unfolding. The reason why is that the earliest research in this space showed the opposite of Sonia's prediction. It was called the Romeo and Juliet effect. And the idea was that if your
给婚姻带来巨大的压力。一位名叫索尼亚的听众写信说，如果大家庭从一开始就不赞成，无论你和伴侣多么契合，这都会影响关系的未来。索尼亚说得对吗，伊莱？是的，她说得对。我觉得这个很有趣，因为你知道，甚至没有多少人知道有一个领域叫做关系科学，对吧？这算是我的大本营学科，我们实际上通过收集数据来试图回答关于关系的问题。而这就是你真正能感受到科学过程展开的时刻之一。原因在于，这个领域最早的研究显示的结果与索尼亚的预测正好相反。这被称为罗密欧与朱丽叶效应。这个想法是，如果你的
parents disapprove or your loved ones disapprove of your relationship, you're going to like your partner even more as a way to sort of give the middle finger to the people. trying to control you. And this is the field thought this was the right answer for, I don't know, 10 or 15 years, but eventually you end up with just an avalanche of studies that show the opposite effect. All else equal, it is much harder to have a good relationship if the important people in your life disapprove than if they approve. I also want to talk a moment about the role of culture in shaping our relationships. Can coming from different cultures impede our patterns? Impede our path to the peaks of Mount Maslow, Eli?
父母不赞成或你爱的人不赞成你们的关系，你反而会更喜欢你的伴侣，以此来向那些试图控制你的人竖中指。这个领域认为这是正确的答案，大概有10年或15年的时间，但最终你会发现研究呈雪崩式增长，显示出相反的效果。在其他条件相同的情况下，如果生命中重要的人不赞成，要维持一段好关系要比他们赞成困难得多。我还想花一点时间谈谈文化在塑造我们关系中的作用。来自不同的文化会阻碍我们的模式吗？阻碍我们走向马斯洛山顶的道路吗，伊莱？
The brief answer is, yes. There are some additional complexities that come with intercultural relationships, partly because our patterns and traditions are a little different, and partly because, you know, with culture comes unconscious understandings of how the world works and how relationships work. But I don't see any reason whatsoever to be cynical about these sorts of relationships. For one thing, there's a lot of great stuff that comes with intercultural relationships, which is the ability to grow and to learn. And those are also wonderful things for relationships. And is it going to be a stronger negative effect that there's some complication over having to align our rituals or is it a stronger positive effect that we get to learn and grow from each other?
简短的回答是，是的。跨文化关系确实带来了一些额外的复杂性，部分原因是我们的模式和传统略有不同，部分原因是，你知道，文化伴随着对世界如何运作以及关系如何运作的潜意识理解。但我看不到任何理由对这类关系抱持愤世嫉俗的态度。一方面，跨文化关系带来了很多美好的东西，那就是成长和学习的能力。这些对关系来说也是美好的事情。这会是一种更强的负面影响，因为必须调整我们的仪式带来了一些复杂性，还是会是一种更强的正面影响，即我们能够彼此学习和成长？
On average, that might be something of a wash. I think the more important thing is not which culture did you bring to the relationship and which culture. did I bring to the relationship, but which culture are we building together in our relationship? What is the culture of you and me? And Chakar, you may remember we talked about this the last time we spoke. I gave the example from my book where I used the phrase belly full of wine. Early on, my wife and I weren't really saying, I love you yet. And this was the sort of shorthand that we developed for conveying a sense of love and safety
平均而言，这可能算是一种扯平。我认为更重要的事情不是你带给这段关系什么文化，我带给这段关系什么文化，而是我们在我们的关系中共同构建了什么文化？你和我的文化是什么？查卡，你可能还记得我们上次谈话时谈到过这个。我举了我书中的例子，我使用了“满腹美酒”这个短语。早期，我和妻子其实还没有真正说出“我爱你”。这是我们为传达爱意、安全感而发展出的某种简写形式
and gratitude for each other. And belly full of wine means nothing outside of the context of our relationship, but it means everything in the context of our relationship. So all of us can build this stuff together, and there's every reason to think that people coming from different cultures can do that just as well as anybody else. When we come back, could the secret to a successful marriage be not two people, but three? You're listening to Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam.
以及对彼此的感激。在我们的关系背景之外，“满腹美酒”没有任何意义，但在我们关系的背景下，它意味着一切。所以我们所有人都可以一起构建这些东西，并且有充分的理由相信来自不同文化的人可以做得和任何人一样好。当我们回来时，成功婚姻的秘诀可能不是两个人，而是三个人？你正在收听的是《隐藏的大脑》。我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。
This is Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. In many cultures, marriage is expected to last for life. It's part of the deal we sign up for. It's why we say, till death do us part. That commitment is reassuring for many. For others, though, it can feel suffocating. Some people in that second category, those who feel constrained, might look to alternative forms of relationships.
这是《隐藏的大脑》。我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。在许多文化中，婚姻被期望持续一生。这是我们签署的协议的一部分。这就是为什么我们说“直到死亡将我们分开”。这种承诺对许多人来说是令人安心的。然而，对另一些人来说，它可能会让人感到窒息。处于第二类中的一些人，即那些感到受到束缚的人，可能会寻求其他形式的关系。
They might lean more heavily on friends or decide to pursue non-monogamy. me. At Northwestern University, Eli Finkel says alternate kinds of relationships can prove useful for many, but they may also be very tricky to navigate. Eli, we heard several examples of listeners who have sought emotional support outside of their romantic relationships. Here's one from Amanda. During COVID, the height of COVID, I started hiking every weekend with my children who really did not enjoy the hike. And then in 2021, I decided to let the kids off the hook. and not take them hiking and still decided to hike every weekend for my mental health.
他们可能会更多地依赖朋友，或者决定追求非一夫一妻制。在西北大学，伊莱·芬克尔表示，其他类型的关系对许多人来说可能证明是有用的，但驾驭它们也可能非常棘手。伊莱，我们听到了几位听众的例子，他们在浪漫关系之外寻求情感支持。这里有一个来自阿曼达的例子。在新冠疫情期间，疫情最严重的时候，我和孩子们每个周末都去远足，孩子们其实并不喜欢远足。然后在2021年，我决定放过孩子们
My best friend heard of my idea and asked if she could join and of course I was excited to have her join. So that was January of 2021. We are now in October of 2025 and we are still hiking every single weekend throughout the year rain or shine. And I think part of what keeps us hiking together every weekend is we process our week, our emotional toys. our troubles with our relationship, with our family, or more. And what we get out of it is this ability to process and support one another and have those emotional needs met outside of our marriage. It takes a lot of burden off our spouses not to have to talk through all the minutia
不再带他们去远足，但为了我的心理健康，我仍然决定每个周末都去远足。我最好的朋友听说了我的想法，问她是否可以加入，当然我很高兴她能加入。那是2021年1月。我们现在是2025年10月，无论风雨交加，我们全年仍然在每个周末去远足。我想我们每个周末继续一起远足的部分原因是我们会处理我们这一周的事情、我们的情感垃圾、我们与伴侣、家庭的烦恼或更多。我们从中得到的是这样一种能力：彼此倾诉和支持，并在婚姻之外满足这些情感需求。这为我们的配偶减轻了很大的负担，不必去讨论所有琐碎的细节
and details of things that are weighing heavy on us. This way we found a way to be supported and feel fulfilled and not have this expectation. that maybe they can't meet for us. And so I hope we continue this tradition for as long as we're physically able to hike on the weekends because it's been so beneficial. So, Eli, it sounds like Amanda and her best friend didn't set out to go on these hikes as a way to take pressure off their marriages,
以及那些压在我们心头的事情的细节。通过这种方式，我们找到了一种获得支持和感到充实的方法，并且没有这种期望，即他们可能无法为我们满足。所以我希望我们能一直保持这个传统，只要我们身体允许在周末远足，因为这太有益了。所以，伊莱，听起来阿曼达和她最好的朋友并不是为了减轻婚姻压力而开始这些远足的，
but that certainly seems to be one of the benefits that they have experienced. We recently talked with the psychologist James Cordova, who describes people who need more emotional support and engagement as ferns, and those who need less as cacti. And in some ways, understanding whether there's a mismatch between you and your partner might be helpful as a first step in thinking about alternative ways to get the right level of support that you need. What do you think about what Amanda and her friend have done? I mean, I love it so much, and I love it whether they're hiking near ferns or hiking near cacti or anywhere else,
但这确实似乎是他们体验到的好处之一。我们最近与心理学家詹姆斯·科尔多瓦进行了交谈，他将需要更多情感支持和投入的人描述为蕨类植物，而将需要较少情感支持的人描述为仙人掌。在某些情况下，了解你和伴侣之间是否存在不匹配，可能是思考获得所需正确支持水平的替代方法的第一步。你对阿曼达和她朋友所做的事情怎么看？我的意思是，我太喜欢了，无论他们是在蕨类植物附近远足，还是在仙人掌附近远足，或者在其他任何地方，我都喜欢
that they're hiking. It's such a wonderful thing. and it's wild how few of us are building activity like that into our everyday lives. I love the idea that you might have what, again, we can call other significant others. Raina Cohn, your colleague, has written a terrific book called The Other Significant Others that talks about, well, what if we put friendship in a more primary role in modern life? Yes, having a spouse that you can share things with is one of the great blessings. that we have. But having somebody else that you can share stuff with is also a great blessing.
他们在远足。这真是一件美好的事，而且令人惊讶的是，我们当中很少有人将这种活动融入到我们的日常生活中。我喜欢这个想法，即你可能拥有我们再次可以称之为“其他重要他人”的人。你的同事雷娜·科恩写了一本极好的书，名为《其他重要他人》，书中讨论了，如果我们把友谊放在现代生活中的更核心地位会怎么样？是的，拥有一个你可以分享事情的配偶是我们拥有的伟大祝福之一。但拥有另一个你可以分享事情的人也是一大祝福。
And it might be the case for many and probably most of us that our spouse is better at nurturing us in some ways than in other ways. And there's no reason why we have to settle for just this one partner. And if, you know, she's good at it, then great. And if not, well, that's kind of unfortunate for me. There are other people that we can have in our lives that can complement these sorts of experiences. And if you have a second person, it's also somebody that you can use to process things in your marriage in a way that might be difficult to do with your spouse. And furthermore, it's worth considering that sometimes when you are your most bandwidth starved, when you're most exhausted, when the kids are screaming and somebody's out of a job, and now you've heard that
对于许多人甚至可能是我们大多数人来说，我们的配偶在某些方面可能比在其他方面更擅长滋养我们。我们没有理由必须满足于仅仅这一个伴侣。如果，你知道，她擅长这一点，那就太好了。如果不是，嗯，那对我和说有点不幸。我们的生活中还可能有其他人可以补充这些类型的经历。如果你有第二个人，这也是一个你可以用来处理婚姻中事情的人，这种方式可能很难与你的配偶一起做到。此外，值得考虑的是，有时当你最缺乏带宽、最筋疲力尽、孩子们在尖叫、有人失业，现在你听说
there's a cancer diagnosis, you know who else is really bandwidth starved? Your spouse. And so finding somebody else who isn't going through most of the things that you're going with alongside you who can be there for you for those sorts of conversations immensely, immensely valuable. The types of romantic relationships we have can change over the course of our lives. Teenage relationships are not the same as couples who've been together for decades. We received a message about later in life love from a listener named Ben. My lady friend and I are both in our older years. after lifelong very satisfying marriages.
有了一个癌症诊断，你知道谁也极度缺乏带宽吗？你的配偶。因此，找到另一个没有经历你所经历的大多数事情、能陪在你身边与你进行那种对话的人，是无比无比宝贵的。我们拥有的浪漫关系类型可能会在我们的一生中发生变化。十几岁的关系与在一起几十年的伴侣是不同的。我们收到了一个关于晚年爱情的信息，来自一位名叫本的听众。我和我的女性朋友都已经进入晚年。在经历了终身非常满意的婚姻之后。
Now we're both widowed, and we have found each other at this time of our lives. All of the lower level needs of the Maslow hierarchy are already met in terms of your marriage conversation. But we're finding great joy in pursuing the self-actualization, the things that are fun and good for each other, We work hard to please each other as well as to meet our own needs. We do not live together, and we get together every week or two for a day or two or three,
现在我们都丧偶了，在这个生命阶段找到了彼此。就你的婚姻对话而言，马斯洛金字塔的所有较低层需求都已经得到满足。但我们发现在追求自我实现、那些对彼此有趣和美好的事情中获得了巨大的快乐，我们努力取悦彼此，并满足我们自己的需求。我们不住在一起，每隔一两周聚在一起一两天或三天，
in order to enjoy each other's company. It seems to me that this is a good relationship, and it speaks very favorably of the way in which you have described what a good marriage is. I'm wondering what the research says about relationships at different life stages, Eli? The literature on how happy people are in their relationship maps on pretty well to the literature on how happy they are with their lives in general. And it looks like people reach a low point in midlife. I think this is driven in part by what used to be called the sandwich experience where
为了享受彼此的陪伴。在我看来，这是一段美好的关系，它非常有说服力地证明了你对什么是好婚姻的描述。我想知道研究对不同人生阶段的关系是怎么说的，伊莱？关于人们在关系中有多幸福的文献，与关于他们在总体生活中有多幸福的文献吻合得很好。看起来人们在中年时达到了低谷。我认为这部分是由过去被称为“三明治经历”的现象驱动的
you've got kids at home and maybe aging parents, those sorts of things. But I have found it fascinating and surprising to discover that people tend to be happier in late life than they are in midlife. And in some ways, that's really surprising. You're dealing with the loss of your friends, often through death. You're dealing with more physical difficulties, including some indignities. And yet, if you look at people's overall satisfaction, it tends to be higher. And that also applies to their relationships. Now, there is a lot of interesting research in the psychology of aging, including by Laura Carstinson at Stanford, that looks at what people tend to prioritize in younger life versus older life. And she observes that as people get older, they focus more on the pleasurable
家里有孩子，可能还有老龄的父母等等。但我发现，一个迷人且令人惊讶的事实是，人们在晚年往往比在中年时更快乐。从某些方面来看，这真的很令人惊讶。你常常要面对朋友的离世。你要应对更多的身体困难，包括一些有失尊严的状况。然而，如果你审视人们的整体满意度，它往往更高。这也适用于他们的人际关系。现在，关于老龄化心理学有很多有趣的研究，包括斯坦福大学的劳拉·卡斯滕森（Laura Carstensen）的研究，该研究探讨了人们在年轻时与年老时倾向于优先考虑什么。她观察到，随着人们年龄的增长，他们更多地关注当下的愉悦
experiences for now. They're more attentive to things that feel good. And they're less focused on building things for the future, perhaps for self-evident reasons. And so it sounds like what Ben has built with his new partner is just a wonderful relationship where they're grateful that they have found each other. They both had beautiful lifelong loves before this. They're grateful that they found each other. They're savoring each other for the now. They're focusing on the positive stuff rather than the indignities or unpleasantnesses of aging. And in that sense, I think they're pretty typical. One thing I noticed in Ben's story is that he and his lady friend, as he calls her, spend time together and enjoy each other's company, but they also spend time apart.
体验。他们对感觉良好的事物更加关注。他们对为未来构建事物的关注减少了，这或许有着不言自听的原因。所以听起来，本和他的新伴侣建立的是一段美妙的关系，他们很感激找到了彼此。在此之前，他们都有过美好的终身挚爱。他们很感激找到了彼此。他们在当下细细品味对方。他们专注于积极的事物，而不是衰老带来的尊严丧失或不快。从这个意义上说，我认为他们相当典型。我在本的故事中注意到的一点是，他和他的“女性朋友”（他这么称呼她）在一起共度时光并享受彼此的陪伴，但他们也会各自度过时间。
As the saying goes, distance makes the heart grow fonder. I'm wondering what having space for ourselves away from our partners might do for our relationships. SELA. One of the things that's fun about bringing data to bear is, yes, we've got the distance makes the heart grow fonder idea, but we also have the out of sight, out of mind idea. So which one is right and when are they right? Those are things that you sort of need evidence to unpack. One of the things I unpacked in the book, the All and Nothing marriage, is what are the ways in which we can ask a little less of our partner in ways that both satisfy ourselves independent of our partner, but also serve as something of a release valve for the relationship is people are choosing
俗话说，距离产生美。我想知道，为自己腾出空间、远离伴侣会给我们的关系带来什么影响。塞拉。运用数据带来的乐趣之一在于，是的，我们有“距离产生美”的观点，但我们也有“眼不见，心不烦”的观点。那么，哪个是对的，它们在什么时候是对的？这些是需要证据来剖析的事情。我在《一切或一无所有的婚姻》（The All-or-Nothing Marriage）一书中剖析的事情之一是，我们可以通过哪些方式对伴侣少要求一点，这些方式既能满足我们独立于伴侣的需求，又能起到关系“释放阀”的作用，比如人们选择
to live apart together. Sometimes people talk about the idea of being a partner. And this is what Ben is doing with his new partner. And it looks like people are able to do that and achieve a level of fulfillment that is just as high as the people who are living together. Now, look, nobody's ever done a study that randomly assigns people to live either together or apart. So I would do the study if we were allowed to do it.
分居异地生活。有时人们会谈论做伴侣的概念。这就是本与他的新伴侣正在做的事情。看起来人们能够做到这一点，并获得与同居的人同样高的成就感。现在，听吧，从来没有人做过一项随机分配人们同居还是分居的研究。所以如果允许的话，我会做这项研究。
So we can't know if there's a causal effect one way or the other. But based on the evidence that we have so far, there's no reason to think people should be frightened of this idea or wary of this idea. And in fact, some of us are more comfortable with intimacy. Some of us are a little less comfortable with intimacy. And at least early evidence suggests that the people who benefit the most, the relationships that benefit the most from living apart are those in which at least one of the partners feels a little bit wary of excessive intimacy.
所以我们无法知道到底是否存在某种因果效应。但根据我们目前拥有的证据，没有理由认为人们应该对这个想法感到恐惧或警惕。事实上，我们中的一些人对亲密关系更自在。我们中的一些人对亲密关系则略微感到不那么自在。至少早期的证据表明，从分居中获益最多、关系获益最多的人，是那些至少有一方对过度亲密感到有些警惕的人。
One of the more controversial topics you mentioned in our first chat was ethical non-monogamy. We heard from many listeners about this. One listener asked that we use his middle name, Christopher. He says that he and his wife found that consensual non-monogamy has benefited their marriage. So we are a couple married 42 years. and we had designed our marriage so that my wife would have been able to have consensual relationships with others when we got married she was involved with someone and you know that continued for a while so and it worked the reason why we designed it that way was that I didn't really meet her needs
你在我们第一次交谈中提到的更具争议的主题之一是道德非一夫一妻制。我们收到了许多听众关于此事的反馈。一位听众要求我们使用他的中间名，克里斯托弗（Christopher）。他说，他和他的妻子发现，协商式非一夫一妻制让他们的婚姻受益。所以我们是一对结婚42年的夫妇，我们在设计婚姻时，就设定了我妻子在结婚时可以与其他人建立合意的关系，当时她和某个人有交往，你知道，这持续了一段时间，而且效果很好。我们这样设计的原因是，我并没有真正满足她的需求
right from the very beginning we click on a lot of levels, but sexually, romantically, we were not a good match. And it worked. What do you make of Christopher's story, Eli? It's not that rare a story. Increasingly, people are receptive to this idea that love might be capacious enough to involve more than two people. I feel compelled to say at the outset here that sometimes you can get like an activist
从一开始就是这样，我们在很多层面上都很合拍，但在性方面和浪漫方面，我们并不是绝配。而且它确实有效。伊莱，你如何看待克里斯托弗的故事？这个故事并不那么罕见。越来越多的人开始接受这样一种观点，即爱可能是包容的，足以容纳两个人以上。我在这里一开始就不得不说，有时你会对非一夫一妻制产生一种激进主义的
orientation toward non-monogamy, that sort of encourages people to do it as the right way or the more evolved way for us to relate. That is not at all, my view. My guess is that more than half of people will probably be happier in a monogamous relationship than in a consensually non-monogamous relationship. But the real question I think we're confronting here is what sort of norms or expectations should we have about monogamy or non-monogamy? And I think our society hasn't quite gotten that right. In particular, by the extent to which that is the self-evident default, right? It's like, well, I'm going to ask a whole bunch of stuff of my spouse, but of course, it's just going to be the two of us for romantic and sexual contact for the next 60 years. We don't think,
倾向，这种倾向有点鼓励人们把它当作我们交往的正确方式或更进化方式。这绝不是我的观点。我的猜测是，超过一半的人在一夫一妻制关系中可能会比在合意的非一夫一妻制关系中更快乐。但我认为我们在这里真正面对的问题是，我们应该对一夫一妻制或非一夫一妻制抱有什么样的规范或期望？我认为我们的社会还没有完全搞对这一点。特别是考虑到这作为不言自明的默认选项的程度，对吧？就像是，“好吧，我要向我的配偶提出一大堆要求，但当然，在接下来的60年里，浪漫和性接触将只有我们两个人。”我们不会去想，
wow, that is a huge ask. Am I really going to ask that of my partner? Is she really going to ask that of me? And if so, what's it going to take to make sure that 30, 40, 50 years from now, we're still excited about each other. What does it mean in terms of how playful we are in the bedroom in terms of how well we take care of ourselves physically? I think because there's such a strong assumption, including a very moralized assumption that of course lifelong love is only two, we don't engage seriously with the magnitude of the ask. And so what I would encourage everybody to do is to treat it as one of the many things that they should be discussing probably before they get married and perhaps revisiting now and again within their marriage. I do think that anybody listening to this would be justified
哇，这是一个巨大的要求。我真的要对我的伴侣提出这个要求吗？她真的会对我提出这个要求吗？如果会，我们需要付出什么来确保30、40、50年后的我们依然对彼此充满激情？这对于我们在卧室里有多么爱玩、我们在身体上照顾自己有多好意味着什么？我认为，正是因为存在如此强烈且高度道德化的假设——即当然终身之爱只能属于两个人，我们才没有认真对待这一要求的巨大程度。因此，我鼓励大家做的是，把它当作他们应该讨论的众多事情之一，可能在结婚前就该讨论，并且或许在婚姻中不时重新审视。我认为任何听到这话的人都是有理由的
in asking themselves, okay, fine, but aren't we going to going to ruin the marriage if we do this? Like, isn't this something that people do for individual fulfillment, but surely it can't be good for the relationship, right? Well, there is evidence on this. People have now studied this in a compelling way. Terry Conley, for example, at the University of Michigan, has some terrific research on consensual non-monogamy. What she does is she recruits a whole bunch of people, I think like 1,500 people who are in monogamous relationships. These are all man, woman, couples. And then, amazingly, she recruited 600 additional people who were in consensually non-monogamous relationships, all of which were involved with somebody of the other gender.
问自己，好吧，这很好，但如果我们这样做，难道不会毁了婚姻吗？比如，这难道不是人们为了个人实现而做的事情，但它肯定对关系没有好处，对吧？嗯，对此是有证据的。人们现在已经以令人信服的方式对此进行了研究。例如，密歇根大学的特里·康利（Terry Conley）对协商式非一夫一妻制有一些极好的研究。她做的是招募了一大群人，我想大约有1500名处于一夫一妻制关系中的人。这些都是男女伴侣。然后，令人惊奇的是，她另外招募了600名处于协商式非一夫一妻制关系中的人，所有这些人都与另一个性别的人有交往。
And what you can do is you can ask these two groups. How happy are you in the relationship? How committed are you to the relationship? Those measures show no difference at all. That is, non-monogamous people, if you just look at their relationship with their primary partner, are no less and no more happy than monogamous people. But it gets interesting when you look at things like trust and jealousy. People in non-monogamous relationships are a little bit more trusting and a little bit less jealous on average than people in monogamous relationships. So I think the best way to conclude this is the difference in overall relationship quality
你可以做的是询问这两组人：你在关系中有多快乐？你对关系的承诺度有多高？这些指标显示不出任何差异。也就是说，非一夫一妻制的人，如果你只看他们与主要伴侣的关系，并不比一夫一妻制的人更不快乐或更快乐。但当你查看信任和嫉妒等指标时，情况就变得有趣了。处于非一夫一妻制关系中的人，平均而言比处于一夫一妻制关系中的人更具信任感，嫉妒心也稍微少一些。所以我认为得出这个结论的最好方法是，关系整体质量的差异
among people who have opted in to monogamy versus opted in to non-monogamy, the difference is very small. And so I think there's plenty of room to think we have a choice here and this is a conversation we should have to get on the same page. Now, we also heard from listeners who did not feel the same way as Christopher about ethical non-monogamy. I want to play your quick note from listener, Kendra. We've watched our friend's marriage disastrously fall apart after they tried this. One partner found his new sexual partner was also better at meeting his emotional and psychological needs too. This has been permanently damaging for the spouse left behind and the kids. So I'm wondering, Eli, given the risks that might be involved in trying something like this,
在选择一夫一妻制的人与选择非一夫一妻制的人之间，差异非常小。所以我认为有充分的理由认为我们在这里有选择，这是一个我们应该讨论以达成共识的话题。现在，我们也听到了一些听众的反馈，他们对道德非一夫一妻制的看法与克里斯托弗不同。我想播放一下听众肯德拉（Kendra）给你的简短留言。我们眼睁睁地看着朋友的婚姻在尝试这种做法后悲惨地破裂了。其中一方发现他的新性伴侣在满足他的情感和心理需求方面也做得更好。这给被抛下的配偶和孩子们带来了永久性的伤害。所以我想知道，伊莱，鉴于尝试这种事情可能涉及的风险，
are there questions that a couple should ask guardrails to put in place if they want to explore non-monogamous relationships? Yes, it's a communication is at the top. But even with full communication, the risk is there. So yes, it's true that Christopher's situation is not that rare, but this new situation also is not that rare. There are risks for sure involved in pursuing consensual non-monogamy. One question is, are you setting things up in advance when there isn't a specific situation that's leading to the conversation? Or is it, hey, I'm now really attracted to this other person. Can we open up the marriage? The first of those conversations is much easier than the second of those conversations. But also, I think it's important to keep in
如果一对夫妇想要探索非一夫一妻制的关系，他们应该提出哪些问题，建立什么护栏？是的，沟通是最重要的。但即使有了充分的沟通，风险依然存在。所以，克里斯托弗的情况并不那么罕见是真的，但这种新情况也并不那么罕见。追求协商式非一夫一妻制无疑伴随着风险。一个问题是，你们是在没有特定引发对话的情况时提前做好安排的吗？还是说，嘿，我现在真的被另一个人吸引了，我们能开放婚姻吗？第一种对话比第二种对话要容易得多。但同时，我认为重要的是要牢记，
mind, the question isn't, is non-monogamy good or is non-monogamy bad? It's, is non-monogamy good or bad relative to the alternative? It isn't the case that monogamous relationships are always fine, but sometimes you see problems with non-monogamous relationships. Right. The fact is, there's difficulties and challenges associated with both. I'm wondering since we first talked in 2018, Eli, has your thinking about marriage and the all-or-nothing marriage evolved since we talked? As I think back to that conversation and to the all-or-nothing marriage, I mostly think we got it right back then. You know, I was writing that book when we had very young kids at home and we had emerged. I spoke openly about this in the book.
问题不是“非一夫一妻制是好还是坏？”而是“相对于替代方案，非一夫一妻制是好是坏？”并不是说一夫一妻制的关系总是没问题，但有时你会看到非一夫一妻制关系出现问题。没错。事实是，这两种方式都伴随着困难和挑战。我想知道，自从我们在2018年第一次交谈以来，伊莱，你对婚姻以及一切或一无所有婚姻的看法自那以后有没有发生演变？当我回想起那次对话以及关于一切或一无所有的婚姻时，我主要觉得我们当时是对的。你知道，我在家里有非常小的孩子时正在写那本书，而我们刚刚走出了那段时期。我在书中公开谈到了这一点。
We had emerged from a difficult period. I myself had a difficult adjustment to parenthood. And we had emerged out of it by the time I was writing the book, but we have continued to emerge out of it in this beautiful way. And so I think what I would like to tell myself from that era when I was first writing that book is things can continue to get better. That even when you've gone through a difficult time, even if somebody's battling a depression, there's no reason to think that this is forever or that if you're going through a spell right now where you think, uh-oh, like things are really tough, you don't have to think because. because they're tough now, they'll be tough always. And I think I'm one example of just, you can really come out the other side of those difficult stretches and just flourish. In our first conversation, Ila, you told me how you tried to keep your connection to your
我们已经走出了艰难时期，当我写这本书时，我们已经走出了困境，而且我们以这种美妙的方式继续走出困境。因此，我想对自己那个刚刚开始写那书的时代说的是，事情可以变得越来越好。即使你经历了艰难时期，即使有人在与抑郁症作斗争，也没有理由认为这是永远的，或者如果你现在正经历一段让你觉得“糟糕，事情真的很艰难”的时期，你也不必认为因为现在艰难，以后就会永远艰难。我想我就是一个例子，证明你可以真正走出那些艰难的阶段并大放异彩。在我们第一次谈话中，伊莱，你告诉我你是如何努力保持与你的
wife, Allison, even in hectic or stressful times. It's been seven years since we had that conversation. So update us. Are there new things that you have come up with to improve the quality of your relationship? Yes. I mean, the thing that we talk about, about back then is, you know, I told a story about traveling to Seattle from Chicago to see my childhood best friend and how that had always been something really fun, but now I was doing it with an eight-month-old and the flight was no fun and the activities that we did were nothing like the activities we used to do before we had those responsibilities. And I just thought, I need to stop trying to be happy. I mean, again, in retrospect, it was a little bit of postpartum depression on
妻子艾莉森（Allison）的联系的，即使在忙碌或压力重重的时期。距离我们那次对话已经过去七年了。所以给我们更新一下吧。你有没有想出什么新方法来提高你们关系的质量？是的。我的意思是，我们当时谈论的事情是，你知道，我讲了一个故事，说我从芝加哥飞往西雅图去看望我童年最好的朋友，这曾经是一件非常有趣的事情，但现在我和一个八个月大的孩子一起去，航班一点也不好玩，我们做的事情也和有这些责任之前做的事情完全不一样。我当时只是想，我需要停止试图去快乐。我的意思是，再次回想起来，这有点像是我当时的产后抑郁症
my part. And slowly but surely, we emerged from that. And to revisit the Mount Maslow metaphor, what I realized that day in Seattle was I needed to descend back down to base camp. This wasn't the time in my life and in my marriage to have the sorts of connection, to be shooting to the top of Maslow's hierarchy in the way that I had been with this amazing woman that I chose to marry. This was a stretch where those efforts I was making, those expectations I was bringing were causing more damage than good. and I thought, I need to stop trying to achieve all that stuff for now.
部分表现。慢慢地，我们不可避免地走出了那段时期。重新审视马斯洛山（Mount Maslow）的比喻，我在西雅图的那天意识到，我需要回到大本营。现在不是我的人生和婚姻中去追求那种连接、去像我与这位我选择娶的非凡女性过去那样冲向马斯洛需求层次顶端的时候。这是一个让我付出的那些努力、带来的那些期望弊大于利的时期。我想，我需要暂时停止试图实现所有这些目标。
And we descended back down to base camp and we geared back up and we took some time and then slowly but surely we started ascending together again. And you know what happens? Kids get older. You end up with more time with your spouse. Now, people aren't as exhausted as they were. The kids are more fun, at least from my point of view, than they were when they were, you know, in the newborn stage.
我们回到了大本营，重新收拾好装备，花了一些时间，然后慢慢地，我们又开始一起向上攀登。你知道会发生什么吗？孩子长大了。你最终有了更多和配偶在一起的时间。现在，人们不像以前那么筋疲力尽了。孩子们变得更有趣了，至少从我的角度来看，比他们处于新生儿阶段时更有趣。
And yes, we've managed to invest in these sorts of ways that it's just been. enormously satisfying and would have been, I think, out of reach during that really difficult, really intense time when the kids were so young. I mean, I love this mountaineering analogy, Eli, because really what you're saying is that sometimes when there's a storm, the smart thing to do might be, in fact, to hunker down, come back to base camp, retreat, you know, come back 500 feet or even 5,000 feet and wait for a time to start ascending once again. That's right.
是的，我们设法以这些方式进行了投入，这简直带来了巨大的满足感，而在孩子们还那么小的那段非常艰难、非常紧张的时期，这简直是遥不可及的。我的意思是，我喜欢这个登山类比，伊莱，因为你真正想说的是，有时当暴风雪来临时，明智的做法实际上可能是躲藏起来，回到大本营，撤退，你知道，退回500英尺甚至5000英尺，等待再次开始攀登的时机。没错。
And that metaphor, as you described it, is just perfect because, you're not descending forever. That's the thing that I think is hard for us. It was hard for me, right? How do you say, uh-oh, this isn't fulfilling me? I'm not fulfilling my spouse. We're having this hard time. We need to stop shooting for the top of the summit anymore. While simultaneously keeping in mind, this isn't forever. This is something we have to do for now, given the resources we have available, the other expectations on us for now, descend back down to base camp, hunker down against the storm, and then the weather lifts a little bit, maybe sort of peek your head out of the tent and say, huh, maybe it's worth climbing a little bit. Let's see how this goes.
正如你所描述的那样，这个比喻简直完美，因为你不是永远在下降。我认为这是对我们来说很难的一点。对我来说这也很难，对吧？你怎么能说，“哦，这没有让我感到满足。我没有满足我的配偶。我们正在经历这段艰难时期。我们需要停止再冲向山顶了。”与此同时，还要记住，这不是永远的。鉴于我们手头可用的资源以及我们目前面临的其他期望，这是我们目前必须做的事情：回到大本营，躲避风暴，然后天气稍微放晴一点，或许把头探出帐篷说：“嗯，也许稍微爬一小段是值得的。让我们看看情况如何。”
Eli Finkel is a psychologist at Northwestern University. He's the author of the All-Or-Nove Marriage, how the best marriages work. With Paul Eastwick, he's the co-host of Love Factually, a podcast that uses rom-coms and other movies to explore the science of love and relationships. Eli, thank you so much for joining me again today on Hidden. Brain. Thanks so much for having me back. Hidden Brain is produced by Hidden Brain Media. Our audio production team includes Annie Murphy Paul, Kristen Wong, Laura Querell, Ryan Katz,
伊莱·芬克尔（Eli Finkel）是西北大学的心理学家。他是《一切或一无所有的婚姻：最好的婚姻是如何运作的》一书的作者。他与保罗·伊斯威克（Paul Eastwick）共同主持了播客《关于爱的真相》（Love Factually），该播客利用浪漫喜剧和其他电影来探讨爱与关系的科学。伊莱，非常感谢你今天再次来到《隐藏的大脑》（Hidden Brain）。非常感谢邀请我再次做客。《隐藏的大脑》由 Hidden Brain Media 制作。我们的音频制作团队包括安妮·墨菲·帕尔（Annie Murphy Paul）、克里斯滕·王（Kristen Wong）、劳拉·克雷尔（Laura Querell）、瑞安·卡茨（Ryan Katz）、
Autumn Barnes, Andrew Chadwick, and Nick Woodbury. Tara Boyle is our executive producer. I'm Hidden Brain's executive editor. If you enjoy today's conversation, please think of a few people who would benefit from it. Share it with them and tell them where they can find Hidden Brain. Many of our listeners find their way to the show based on recommendations from others. I would love it if you would be an ambassador for the show. I'm Shankar Vedantam. See you soon. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
奥特姆·巴恩斯（Autumn Barnes）、安德鲁·查德威克（Andrew Chadwick）和尼克·伍德伯里（Nick Woodbury）。塔拉·博伊尔（Tara Boyle）是我们的执行制片人。我是《隐藏的大脑》的执行主编。如果你喜欢今天的对话，请想几位能从中受益的朋友。与他们分享，并告诉他们去哪里可以找到《隐藏的大脑》。我们的许多听众都是根据别人的推荐找到这个节目的。如果你能成为该节目的形象大使，我将不胜感激。我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆（Shankar Vedantam）。我们回头见。这个剧集还没有评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。